Hello everybody, hello, hello, give me a sec, let me, oh I
have to like close some tabs today, uh, where's my
controller, yes, I can finally use the controller, wow, all
right, let me, I guess I have to be a bit higher up, give me
a sec, my immersion, oh no, oh, just, just a little bit
high, I actually don't even know if this is synced, up to an
actual controller.
Let's try this out.
Guys, I have a little bit of a problem.
I might be, like, behind on a lot of work because I might be
running away from my responsibilities by playing Deadlock
and my manager is not happy about that.
He's like, you're doing your work, right?
And I was like, yeah.
I'm really bad at it though I'm at work right now yeah yeah
um I just don't understand Ivy I don't I I've been trying to
to get through I I hate that like in deadlock you have to
have 15 games on three characters and i'm like if i could
just one trick rem i would like oh my god if i i understand
rem i understand him but like i've been i'm like three games
i need three more wins on ivy and then i'm set to go and
play rank but and i could just one trick rem the entire time
in rank i don't care uh i don't understand i could play
support i don't understand i try to run gun ivy and it's how
to do damage.
I just don't understand.
I don't, I feel like I'm shooting at stuff, but yet somehow
I'm not shooting enough.
I'm like, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't understand.
I shoot, but why damage low?
Why is damage low?
I've been trying like so many different builds and I'm like,
I don't understand.
Why damage low?
why why can't i do damage uh i do lots of healing but yeah
so i've been sort of playing deadlock till six in the
morning lately and that's why i had to take an extra day off
because by so that's angry okay let me give him a little bit
of food uh let me give him a little bit of food
sorry i had to i had to give him a little bit of food before
we start um where is i at But where was I even talking about
us?
I know I was talking about Ivy, but it's like, I don't, I
don't know.
I, I, I, I, but that's why, that's why I take an extra day
off because I was like super behind on, I was super behind
on a lot of work stuff.
And then imagine how to sit me down is like, look, Doki,
you, we, we need to get through some actual work stuff.
running away from your responsibilities to deadlock every
night.
And I was like, but, but, but gaming is so fun.
Gaming is like escapism.
What's the point of gaming if I can't escape from my
responsibilities?
Like, what's the point of gaming at all?
To have, to, to, to have work is to run away from work.
So why don't you play?
Because I like playing Deadlock off stream Because I can
comfortably be bad at the game Without anyone watching me
bad To be bad at the game That's why I like playing off
stream Because I know I'm dog shit But sometimes I don't
want to be dog shit for content Is that too much to ask for?
I want to be privately dog shit.
I sometimes I just want to be bad off stream in private.
I don't want to show it to the world how bad I am at the
video game.
I,
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Petition the McDiokie Steam account.
Never invisible status.
So magic can catch your inner lies.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
chat thank you thank you yes exactly i want to be bad at my
off time i i i want to be dog shit without having to use it
for content i just want to be a private dog shit at be
privately dog shit at a game right so is that too much to
ask for guys is it really too much to ask for streaming it
i'll be streaming deadlock anyway in two days you can you
can laugh at my gameplay in two days guys don't worry all
right uh all right let me grab let's see i'm trying to
remember the program that you have to use for uh google it i
don't remember i don't know if this does have like if it's
like buying into a controller vtuber controller program I
have to do that because I don't remember what I forgot what
the plug-in is called now okay oops pick uping today is that
what it's called or is it now oh there it is I found it I
don't remember all right let's test it out to see if it
works because I'm I didn't try it on this skin suit
Let's see.
Let's see if it works.
Oh, did it not?
I did not boot up.
Hello.
EXE.
I clicked it.
Couldn't connect.
What do you mean you couldn't connect?
What is that supposed to mean?
Alright, give me it.
Whoops.
Allow.
Oh, yeah!
What it does!
Wow!
Look at that!
my little thumb my wow well at least you guys can now remind
me of what the pro look at that whoa you see that what the
tiny little like little the little tiny immersion see i took
you out of the immersion just to bring you back in it's the
sacrifices we have to make you know um uh okay that update
Uh, wait, give me a sec, sorry.
I don't have ADHD.
I just have a lot of stuff going on in my head right now.
All right.
Dad update.
Oh, there's several dad updates.
But basically, uh, okay.
I'll give you guys a funny one.
A saint.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
you.
Hey, Joki.
Thank you for introducing me to Onimusha.
I finished the game and grabbed all the cosmetic.
You're in for a fun time.
We'll be here to help.
I cannot wait.
I'm so excited.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, took him to, okay, the last three days.
So there's three days of that.
There's mostly two dad updates.
Um, the first one was, it was really funny, uh, when I was
like at the dog park and I brought dad there.
So he saw an owner there and he owner so he ran straight to
the which is very surprising because it was a guy you know
it was you know usually he doesn't give a fuck about men um
but then I guess he really wanted someone to touch him today
so I touch him guys I pet him sorry that sounded really bad
I I pet him guys I give him I give him pets and cuddles but
sometimes he wants like more he wants he loves he craves
attention okay he's a needy he's a needy little bitch so um
he loves attention from anyone um he so you saw a guy there
and he ran straight to the owner and then it like the dog
part is set up in a way where there's another section of the
dog part but you don't see it when you enter the dog part
you have to like go past because there's like a pillar or
something like a giant like wall that blocks it so um he ran
to the first owner and it was a guy and he got to a certain
distance we saw a second owner and it was a girl and it was
so funny he was like going directly like uh directly saw the
girl and then he did a little sharp 90 degrees turn to the
guy was like already getting ready like he grouched down
arms open he's like aww it's so he's like aww like oh come
here and he saw the girl and he instantly did a fucking 90
degrees turn he's like went straight to the girl and I was
like I'm sorry I he changed his mind He's like, not you.
Yeah, he locked it.
He like instantly changed his target.
And then goes like, oh, hey there.
And he's like, yay.
Women, not love women.
Hey, oh, never mind.
There's a lady.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
It's not you.
I'm sorry.
Just have a pee-pee and he doesn't like that.
He likes women more.
All right.
Today, today, um, he stole a random ball at the dog part.
So now I have an extra dog ball.
Like it's not really a story for that one.
We were at the dog part.
It was just me and him, but someone left her.
I didn't realize this, but someone left their ball, um, at
the entrance of the dog part.
We didn't see it at first.
And then like when we left, um, dad saw it as we went left
and he was like, bah.
And then he like grabbed onto it and then took it home.
He's like, it's mine now.
And I was in the elevator waiting.
And then he discovered the ball has a squeaker inside.
And then he's like, oh my god, wait.
It's Christmas.
It's Christmas and my birthday.
The ball even has a squeaker.
And he's like, squee, squee, squee, squee, squee, squee.
And he was so excited.
He's like, free ball.
I mean, everything is technically free for him.
But for me, I'm like, oh, nice.
Free ball.
I was like a little worried because I was like, oh, why did
they just left the ball here?
I was like, I hope there's these men not carrying anything.
I should have washed it, but he wouldn't let it go because
he like brought it.
Like he was just, he had it in his mouth and I didn't want
to touch it because it was literally this random ball that
was left there at the dog part.
So I didn't want to touch it, you know, like, so then I was
just like, well, like, all right, I guess it's yours now.
I didn't want to, I don't really want to touch it and remove
it from your mouth.
So, so, yeah, it's fine.
It keeps like, oh my God, treasure at the dog park.
Anyway, so now I have someone's random fucking dog ball now.
Back home now.
Got another new dog, new dog ball.
He has so many.
He loves fucking playing fetch.
But yeah, we have a, he brought it home.
I didn't want to touch it.
So it's just there now like I was just like I don't know how
long it's been I mean it must be there for at least a day
Because I didn't see it yesterday.
So I don't know how long it's been there.
I don't know why they left The problem is I don't know why
they left it So I'm like I hope there's no like it's not
carrying like the hanta virus or some shit Like I hope a rat
didn't poop on this ball And now we're like I hope some bugs
didn't lay eggs on the ball And now I'm bringing back like
fucking termites or some shit Or please.
So I'm just like, oh man.
This doesn't bite me in the ass for bringing it home.
Well, he brought it home.
I didn't have a choice in that matter.
Yeah.
So I should wash it.
I just didn't want to touch it when he brought it back.
But I'll wash it later.
What do you?
I gave you food.
What did you want?
All right, I'm going to ignore him.
What else I want to talk about?
Let's see.
I wrote some stuff down.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so we're playing War Dogs tomorrow.
And then, okay, this is like...
This is a crazy-ass...
Wait, let me see.
I sent this to a friend.
Let me see if I can find the exact quote.
He's, yeah, I'm just going to try to ignore him right now.
I'm just trying to ignore him.
Let's see.
Alright, so for those who don't know, the next three, oh,
wait, is it today?
Oh, shit, I didn't realize.
Oh, wait, sorry.
Wait, is it today or tomorrow?
What date is it today?
so the next three days or sorry including today is a wild
day because uh tomorrow we're gonna be playing war dogs you
know uh so for those who don't know today is the kirk
aversary tomorrow is deadlock patch and then september 11th
is september 11th so we're gonna have some wild like it's a
wild week this week the thing is i'm a little worried about
tomorrow because war dogs is a roleplay-esque war game
tomorrow is a role-play war-esque game and i'm a bit worried
about the voice chat tomorrow
I'm a bit worried It's not Oh, it really depends No, I'm
gonna be playing Well, I'm not gonna I'll be On a team With
sure for in them And they're like hard role players And
That's why I'm a little I'm a little worried What's gonna be
happening in VC tomorrow I And I'm a little, I'm a little,
yeah, the voice chat's gonna be, uh, it's gonna be a little
bit cooked tomorrow.
So I'm just giving you guys a warning in advance that
tomorrow's voice chat might get a little wild.
And I don't know what I can do.
I don't, I don't know what we, we, we don't know what
they're gonna say.
We're just going to have to brace ourselves with what's
going to happen tomorrow in War Dogs.
Yeah,
and I think I'm most worried about, because like, I know
some of them were like, oh, wait, I'm not going to say it.
I just know that tomorrow is going to be a little wild.
So I'm going to give you guys a little warning in advance
that War Dogs might get a little wild tomorrow.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I actually saw that tweet.
I saw that tweet.
I know exactly what tweet you're referencing right now.
But that wasn't Deadlocked.
That wasn't in War Dogs.
What are stuff that I wanted to, like, tell you guys about?
I know I booked Marks, so this is a life update.
Sorry, I didn't prepare properly.
Usually for life updates, I'll put in a Discord.
But today I'm going to...
just bookmarked oh yeah so people for those who don't know
what's going on in the world right now people uh uh you can
now uh control uh like i think like they like uh let's see
you know how they mapped out the complete brain and central
nervous system of an adult male fruit fly and then
apparently they like uploaded it uh they uploaded it onto
like the internet so like anyone can with the brain of a fly
uh so so yeah and then um but it's like not a real fly by
the way it's not a real fly so it's like this like
reconstruction uh yeah they made the that fly fucking play
dude but it's like a reconstruction ai like an ai
reconstruction of like a digitally simulated uh fly and like
it's like a fully constructed like brain and nervous system
of an adult fly do things online so it's like literally like
black mirror and type shit like he's like this fly is in the
simulation he doesn't know that he doesn't know he's not
real but he thinks he's real like that's like really up like
we have this fucking bright fly the brain of a fly online
right now but he doesn't know he's online he doesn't know
he's not real like and people around the world are making
him do things like there's a video there's one where someone
made this fly to play beat saber for eternity like we're one
step closer to making artificial human brains and trap them
so they so this one person with with with With this
virtually uploaded brain of a fly made the fly fucking be
trapped in this eternal room playing Beatsaber for the rest
of his fucking virtual life.
Like, I thought that one was, that was crazy.
Like, his whole existence is to just play Beatsaber.
There's another one where, um, there was another one where,
like, they, they program his brain to, like, play bad apple,
but that one was, that one's a little fucked up.
There was one where they taught the fly how to drive a car.
I think that one was also crazy.
Beep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, I think you're slowly convincing me to want a
wiener dog when I, when I decided to get a dog.
idea yes and no when you get a weiner dog that would be the
only dog breed you'll ever own for the rest of your life
there's like actually like i don't know what it is it's like
corgis too i don't know because like if you own other dogs
you'll have you'll like try out different dog breeds and
everything but when you get a weiner dog that is your whole
life now like you would not want any other dog breeds after
that like when you have a weiner dog it's like ride or die
like you only you it's from here on out yeah it's because
they're like they're very they have a very unique
personality compared to like um other dogs they're very like
they're very demanding they're very needy and they would
want like cuddles and stuff all the time because they'll
always want like they always want to be near you because
like dad does not care about the bed unless i'm in he's like
by the way it's really fucked okay this is a problem like i
have to like i need more i need to buy more stairs because
he has because i took the stairs away because i realized um
when i had the because i didn't want him to like uh because
i realized when he's on the bed i can't like sometimes he
jumps off the bed um so i got worried because he doesn't use
the stairs even though the stairs is like right in front of
him so i took the stairs away but then he realized because
my new bed the He finally figured out that for my new bed,
the mattress is lower.
Like the bed frame is on the ground.
So the mattress is lower.
So he finally realized he can make the jump on top of my
bed.
He's, he figured it out.
He was like, wait, I can make this jump.
Like he finally figured it out.
I don't, I don't, he's like, oh my, I can reach it.
So like that's a problem.
I have to, that's a problem right now because I would fall
asleep like he'd be on the ground I let him on he has a bed
on the ground I fall asleep and then I wake up and he's in
the bed with me he's like hey I won't shit you oh shit you
found out hey yeah you exploited the patting a new patch
notes dude I did patch this out yeah so then I'm like oh I'm
like how did you get here like and I realized when and I
pretended to fall sleep one time and i realized he waits
until i fall asleep and then jumps onto my bed and then like
and then like like uh huddles under my bed sheets like he
figured it out and i was like he feels like oh my god he's
like can't stop me when you're asleep yeah duck thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you uh so much gave us
million different reasons why this is a bad idea We're going
to reach the Soma universe before we reach cyberpunk.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
So like, but yeah, like honestly, I love weiner dogs Um, I
think I've had I had a thought about getting a different
type of dog breed.
I know it's crazy I got out of the pro for one second.
I went like sentient.
I got out of the The weiner dog hypnosis, but I realized it
was a very bad idea and dad was right.
I should never get a dog breed other than weiner dogs um for
one second i broke out of the trash like what am i like no
that's wrong that's how dare i have like an independent
thought outside of that um it was like either a cork i
realized corgis and winter dogs are like mortal enemies they
hate each other both long but they're the wrong type of long
um dad fucking hates corgis like wrong wrong long wrong type
of long He's like, you're not like me.
I'm better than you.
Yeah.
So I had, um, uh, but that hates corgis.
Doesn't matter what kind.
Well, it doesn't matter.
Every time he sees a corgi, he fucking hates them.
Um, net first, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
He's like, not same.
We are not the same.
Uh, the bed's going to need to look like a pyramid.
Thank you.
a super chat thank you thank you um and then i also thought
about ashib as well but that real ashibi news are really
hard to take care of because they're also they're like also
similar in winter dogs they're very um they're very i'll say
brady and there's another word for it they're very hard to
look after uh because very independent dogs and they're also
very loud as well so They're basically a bigger version of
dad.
You know, I tolerate dad raddiness because he's a small dog,
you know.
Like I can, it's hard.
It's easier to manage because he's smaller, you know.
Yeah, like, yeah, they're very, Shiba Inus are very high
maintenance.
But then like, but then like Ashima is like bigger than dad,
like a lot bigger than dad.
So, um, yeah.
so it would be a lot harder to manage but i am i i have
thought about getting a second dog lately uh just to keep
dad company um and uh you know i feel like he would love to
have like you know little brothers the little brother me
most likely not little sister a little brother um not like a
puppy i don't want to like go through like puppy training
all over again so slightly older maybe like already a year
old but i have been thinking about it um but also i'm plan
if i do plan on getting a second dog uh it'll be after maybe
like during the holidays because i'm so fully booked this
the rest of the year where i have to be i'm flying a lot uh
i'm flying like at least once a month the next like all the
way till december i'm flying at least once a month so i'm
planning on doing that like later on in the year when i've
stopped flying because like I don't want to, you know, I
don't want to have to deal with the dogs.
They're taking care of two dogs while I'm away once a month,
basically.
Fire, thank you, a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do not get two dogs.
I made that mistake and now I just have to take care of two
pets separately.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I remember that conversation I had with my manager because
my initial thought was like, what about two dogs?
They'll, they'll like, you know, occupy themselves.
with each other and my manager was like no they're doki is
just gonna dad's just gonna teach the other dog to be to be
like him and now you'll have two dogs asking you for
attention like he's just gonna he's gonna teach the other
dog all the things he's learned uh being raised by me how to
take advantage of me and then both of them are gonna wear me
down Yeah, double the trouble.
That would teach him.
Yeah, you'll teach him what he's learned.
Then both of them will use their powers combined to fuck
with me.
So, like I said, I've been thinking about it.
When was I?
Oh, I got distracted with this topic.
What was I talking about before?
Let's see.
Also, Quail, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Someone had to put in Minecraft and did nothing.
It was a super chat.
Thank you.
Ordered stuff.
Um.
What was I talking about before?
Was it?
Oh, I was talking about the fly.
Nate, thank you.
It was super chat.
Thank you.
My, my family, my entire life has had at least one or three
mini doxins.
They're the best cully buddies.
Usually here have between four to five dogs, between four
people.
It's good.
Thank you.
It's a super chat.
You bark while she's streaming.
You can get more food.
Thank you.
We travel so much, Doki.
Are you sure you get how-to dogs, especially when it teaches
him all the forbidden stuff?
And even Super Chat, thank you.
Like I said, it'll be like after all the traveling because
next year, I told my manager I want to travel less next
year.
I'm really, I think that's why I'm also really tired lately
and have been like streaming where I had to take more breaks
because I'm like, like if I wasn't traveling, I would have
so much energy.
traveling is the thing that takes the most energy out of me
because i fucking hate flying like i think like the more
i've flown the more i just hate hated it and i just i don't
know i just don't like flying at all and it's just also like
being social and everything it's just a lot you know in
general so i think that's what's been tiring me out the most
because i usually have you know in the past i had much more
energy much more like you know my schedule has been like um
uploaded late recently and stuff like that and it's just
i've been like so tired and i'm always like playing catch-up
too so like i told my manager like next year i do want to
travel a lot less because i just want to focus on stream
like i just want to focus like not just only streaming but
you know i just want to focus on making content at home
that's really it i just want to i just want to focus on
making content at home and uh not flying too much next year
i Like, I was like, are you sure, Doki?
Are you sure it's not playing Deadlock till 7 a.m?
Yes, I'm sure.
Playing video games till 6 or 7 in the morning has nothing
to do with my tiredness.
There is no correlation at all between the either.
I think it's the flying.
It has no effects whatsoever regarding my energy levels.
It's the flying, guys.
It's all on the flying.
I know for sure.
Playing video games all the way till 6 in the morning,
messing up my sleep schedule, and also making me wake up
super late at 3 p.m.
It has nothing to do with why I'm so tired every day.
No reason.
And also the fact that I'm delaying my, running away from my
responsibilities and my work because of these video games
has nothing to do with why i'm so tired always behind on
work
playing video games it makes me happy yo thank you miss
richard thank you thank you okay um what are stuff oh my god
there's so many life updates news updates uh oh yeah a lot
of shit got leaked on steam apparently i'll brush upon it
because it's giant spoilers i did see the spoilers um on uh
the steam achievement like leaks so for those who don't know
there was a giant leak right on steam where uh steam
achievements were being leaked on unreleased games and that
includes kingdom hearts i won't spoil it because i know some
people have been waiting years for kingdom hearts for but if
you're like me and you don't about spoilers like honestly
like spoilers does not ruin my day i fucking love spoilers
because i cannot wait i i i'm like one of those kids growing
up where um when i'm reading a book i skip to the ending
because i'm like oh what's gonna happen like i read
something really juicy i'm like wait like oh my god what's
gonna happen and i literally like go like just skip to the
ending just like oh so that's what happens like i'll go
through like like like skip through chapters to be like oh
shit oh my god and then go back to reading uh i don't do not
i i read wikipedia regarding spoilers um if like you know
like if there's a new movie comes out i'm curious about the
movie before watching it i will read the wiki summary or
like the plot synopsis or i would like look up the ending
just because i'm just curious and before i watch uh because
i just love spoilers i don't care i don't really care much
about getting spoiled or anything um i just uh uh i like
knowing what's happening even though i don't like like even
though i don't like you know You know how some people would
want to experience it live and what's happening and
whatsoever I like knowing in advance what's happening.
I don't do that for I just so you guys know I don't do that
for the games I stream That's that's the one thing I I don't
do it for Um, but anyway So Uh for this is why I also don't
stream games that already know the that's because some
people are like Oh, why don't you stream Undertale?
Or like, why don't you stream?
I don't know.
I'm trying to think of games that have like watched
playthroughs of or like know the spoilers of already.
Or like, oh, why don't you stream this game or that game?
Because I already know what's going to happen.
I already read the Wikipedia.
Like, I don't stream Undertale because I know exactly how
the gameplay.
Like, I've seen playthroughs of it and I've read the
synopsis of the game itself.
So, like, I won't have like, whoa, you know, I don't want to
have like a genuine reaction because I already know what's
going to happen.
Just because I've read the spoilers of what's gonna happen
like So That what I stream like if it's like a story game
and like what choose to stream stream for you guys is like
games.
I have not spoiled myself on anything and I don't know
what's gonna happen Because I obviously like, you know, I
want genuine reactions and I don't want to like play it up
like be like, oh my god Oh, what is this?
Whoa
All right um so because i want to experience it with you
guys too i want to have like i want to be able to experience
like stuff unfolding it with you guys um but anyway i
spoiled myself with kingdom hearts because i don't know if
i'll ever to be fair i don't know if i'll ever stream
kingdom hearts just because i don't know i feel like kingdom
hearts is like a game where everybody plays but not really
like streaming wise it doesn't have like a big viewership
watching it Like, Kingdom Hearts 3 was so fucking tight.
I don't even want to go through Kingdom Hearts 3.
I want my Kingdom.
Oh, yeah.
And the Kingdom Hearts 2 has, like, fucking three-hour,
like, tutorial.
Yeah.
We just don't remember.
Kingdom Hearts 2, the tutorial itself is, like, three-plus
hours long.
And it is, like, 90% cutscenes.
Yeah.
So, like, I don't really want to go through that.
I think that...
Like, it's great.
You get to meet Roxas and all of them, but that's just,
it's, it's streaming-it-wise, it's just me watching a movie
for the first three hours.
Anyway, so I know the spoilers for Kingdom Hearts 4.
I'm not going to spoil it here on stream, because I know
some people have been waiting for Kingdom Hearts 4 for a
long time.
Like, what, this game is, like, what, 20 years old now?
It's crazy.
Wait, is it?
Holy shit, I just realized Kingdom Hearts is like 20 plus
years old.
uh release date oh my even more wait oh my god it's like 20
plus years more years old uh but anyway i will i'll just say
that in the um what was leaked was basically uh the worlds
the worlds got leaked so like people were expecting like you
know like what what are the new worlds that they're planning
on adding in Kingdom Hearts and through the achievements
that got leaked and then so people were like oh shit like
some people are really excited about it because there are I
will say there is a very uh there was a world I did not
expect them to add for Kingdom Hearts 4 only because uh it's
just wild because I'm like I'm like thinking holy shit like
you know actors for it and every I think you're also
thinking like which version is this too that's I'll try to
I'm trying to be as vague as possible yeah I'm trying to be
as vague as possible but it's like which version of this
world is it too if it's like then is it the newer version or
is it there's several versions is it the newer version, the
old version, or the older version.
So I guess we're going to find out later on Dave.
The vague post-queen.
Yeah.
I don't want it, please.
That's all I'll say.
That's everything I'll say about the Kingdom Hearts leak.
Anyway, what else?
What else?
Oh, yeah, look at this.
Okay, also, I want, I've been wanting to talk about this for
a while, but, uh, do you guys know how, like, a lot of new
movies are getting, like, sorry, a lot of old movies are,
for this one, no, I want to spoil them, so just Google
Kingdom Hearts Steam Achievement Links, and you'll see it.
Um, let's see, wait, this is the last thing I want to talk
about.
There were so many things, oh, yeah, I'll talk about two
things, um, because this is, like, current events, but for
those who have never been in Japan, uh, so in Japan, like,
everybody knows, like, it's, like, the public transport is,
like one of the biggest things about like traveling to japan
how the public transport in japan is really good and very
convenient so uh what happened is that um yeah i'm the doki
news channel doki news network um they uh finally decided to
replace the mascot which was a penguin the penguin was the
official mascot for the uh public transport in japan um it
was really cute it was called So let's see, squeak, squeak
card.
It was a penguin.
It was just a plain old penguin.
And anyway, they recently announced that the penguin is
graduating.
I was like, from what?
Like, does the penguin stream?
Like, what does he even do?
He's just there.
Like, why does he need a graduate?
What did he do?
What did the penguin do?
Was there a Google document I should be reading?
Like, did...
Did he cheat on someone?
Oh my god, was he in the files?
What the fuck did the penguin do to require him to graduate?
Like, was he not paid enough?
He's just, he's just there.
He shows up for several photo shoots.
What else do you have to do?
Like, the twin longer was insane.
Like, was he getting paid?
Was he being abused by his company?
Like, you know, why pay?
Why is he graduating?
I don't understand.
Disagreement with management?
Brandon, think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I hope you're doing wonderfully.
How are you enjoying Oni Musha?
I used to play Oni Musha all the time.
I was kidding.
I hope you're enjoying the new one as much as I am.
I am enjoying the new one a lot.
It's a very hard game, though.
It's definitely...
Uh, very hard game.
But yeah, I was like, why is he retiring?
So, I was so confused.
Because I was like, why the fuck is he?
Why the fuck are they graduating a fucking penguin mascot?
Apparently it has to do with rights or some shit.
Because like, the original penguin was not even, the penguin
wasn't even, like, didn't even originally, uh, wasn't even
originally designed for the subway.
It was like a character from a children's.
book back when uh like years ago like before the subway was
even made um so it was apparently a character from a
children's book that the subway company just adopted as like
their mascot so then they're like we're finally gonna have
our own mask but i think at this point like this is your
mascot like i okay to be fair the choices they especially
with the choices they gave they gave the citizens to vote on
and there's like lots of memes right now because like uh the
choices are pretty bad not gonna
yeah i know i think it just paid for the rights for it i
feel like i i feel like it's not like i don't know i i don't
know why like i don't know the exactly the legalities of
what the fuck is going on why the cat just like officially
adopted as like their official mascot i mean it's already
sort of like everybody recognizes as the as like the mascot
anyway they're getting they're having like a public vote
right now as we all know you should i don't know maybe in
japan people in japan people are less uh trolly i guess i
don't know anymore though because of the memes coming up but
um usually if it was anywhere else in the world that's not
japan we would not have public votes for anything because uh
because um the first thing we What's the funniest thing we
can vote for?
I don't know if you guys remember the Mountain Dew.
We all know the Pitbull one where he was sent to Alaska.
And there's one where people had to vote on a name to name a
boat and became, yeah, Boaty McBoatface.
And then there was the Mountain Dew flavor of Boatweight.
That one was really bad.
it on screen I will say I'll say number two but there was
one where Mountain Dew made a poll to name their newest soft
drink and number two was gushing granny I won't say number
one I this is why in NA in any English-speaking countries we
do not do we do not do popular anymore because for us when
we do popular vote we pick the funniest one i won't say no
okay i don't know about the mountain do one i or the most
most troll we do the most troll one we did
so anyway in japan right now i actually don't know the poll
is up right now but these are the
mascot that's gonna be replacing the sweet penguin um and
everyone's like like oh a obviously and then everyone looks
at b and it was like what the fuck is what the fuck is that
so there's there's a lot of memes right now of b because
it's so i don't like i don't know Maybe it's the face.
There's there's I feel there's something wrong with B Like
he knows things and I love all right this one.
I saw this artwork Training like trained face, so this is
from This from this artist Japanese grimace.
I don't I don't I don't think I think grimace will be
Grimace is less murder murdery looking than the bee um i'll
show you so people have started making you might have seen a
lot of memes going around because my sleep paralysis demon
so i send a link to the artist but there's been a lot of
interesting memes going around uh with bee and i'll show you
this one that i just linked on in chat uh is this one
V is like a skin walker.
So I feel like, I think V might win.
I think, I'm pretty sure V's gonna win, guys.
That's gonna be on your Suka card when you go visit Japan.
Yeah, the thing is, we would pick V.
But what the people in Japan carry out are, what the people
in Japan carry out are wishes, though.
if they pick the funniest one.
It would, I will say, someone like did like a photoshop of
the cards just to see like what it looks like.
I think I, I, like if you compare like the, the penguin card
with, with being, it looked like he fucking murdered the
penguin.
Now it looks like some like horror analog game.
where he fucking he just murdered a penguin and just took
over the card like it's so ominous yeah yeah the card is
like cursed he like ate the penguin so yeah so that's what's
that's what's going on in Japan right now they're gonna have
a huge vote on who's gonna replace the penguin after he
graduates they really had no uh those are the options they
have uh what do you mean i think that you are the best
options okay last update last uh world update but um i know
i talked about this before but like i said like recently i
feel like this is like the last like two to three years
which i've noticed is that Recently, they've been
re-releasing a lot of older movies with, I feel like, and I
personally think this is the reason why they re-released a
lot of older movies and theaters to sell more popcorn
buckets.
I don't know what the fuck is going on, but like every, I
guess like, there's like a popcorn bucket craze right now.
Also, I saw the Resident Evil popcorn bucket, and that's not
a fucking bucket.
That's just a, that's like just a lunch bag.
Anyway, this is the Resident Evil popcorn bucket.
That's $40, by the way.
It's just a...
Oh, wait.
It's not even 40.
It's getting resold for $70.
People are scalping it for $70.
And it's like...
I mean, it's literally a lunch bag.
But anyway, I think that...
I literally think that's the reason why a lot of movies
nowadays are getting re-released into theaters because
people are just trying to capitalize on the popcorn bucket
phase like everything has to be a popcorn bucket now and
it's like they're all like super there are cool ones i i own
the zootopia one because i thought i really i just thought i
was super clever like so there's some that's really clever
and it's practical it's actually a popcorn bucket but then
there's some that are like how like i can fit like what like
one cup of popcorn like there's some popcorn buckets that
you can only fit like one cup of popcorn because everything
else is just decoration or it's like a fucking bitch to
clean like like how do i clean this there's electronics in
my popcorn bucket how the fuck am i gonna clean all of this
like i can't even put it in the dishwasher like
yeah yeah a lot of them are like impractical but i think
like i honestly think this is why like popcorn like people
are just like getting like older movies back in 30 years
because you're like we can make popcorn buckets for it now
oh my god like oh Oh my god, guys, we could capitalize on
the popcorn bucket craze.
Anyway, so I wanted to talk about popcorn buckets because
it's also really popular in theme parks.
I don't know where it started from.
I don't know if it started from theme parks and then went
straight to movie theaters or it started from movie
theaters.
popcorn buckets too I just know like uh um it's like very
popular in theme parks as well now um so what if we make a
dragon popcorn so true we wait wait a minute wait a minute
somebody's cooking right now um but um I saw pop oh yeah
there's also cars there's a um there's like okay I would
actually, I think that, I think it's really funny, but also
how many fucking popcorn can I fit?
They released the Cars popcorn bucket, too.
They re-released Cars for the 20th anniversary and then
launched a, launched a Cars popcorn bucket where it's
literally just Lightning McQueen.
It was Lightning McQueen as a popcorn bucket.
And then you put the popcorn in him.
Anyway, I wanted to talk about popcorn bucket because, oh
yeah, no, this one I think is inconvenient.
So Supergirl had a popcorn bucket and it was Loba.
And I'm like, that's like a cup of popcorn.
Like, so this is what it looks like without the popcorn
part.
And I'm just like, what the, how am I eating popcorn?
out of this.
Like, this is what it looks like, by the way.
What about the popcorn?
Like, yeah, it looks sick.
It actually looks like a... It looks like collectible.
And then you buy it for the popcorn bucket.
Like...
Like, what the fuck is this?
Chonky-goon bucket with Longoon Cup where the neck is
excessively...
Oh!
So you're giving... Every time you use a straw, you're
giving the Longoon a little kiss.
Mwah!
That kiss your me this is a good night all right wait this
is not the actual popcorn bucket i wanted to show you guys
but i realized i was just looking at the um i was looking at
the popcorn buckets that are being sold right now in um in
movie theaters but anyway i want to talk about popcorn
buckets because um because halloween is getting closer and
in universal in universal japan they just announced a uh
they were going they're doing a resident evil collab uh in
universal japan and they recently i think like this week
they announced the resident evil actually like the actual
popcorn bucket for the resident evil collab for universal
japan and
the liquor's popcorn
I just, okay, now I'm gonna lie, like, the fact that it's
called liquor's popcorn, like, there's kids there, by the
way, they just, yeah, that's important, just for the pot,
you give, give the liquor a kiss before you grab the
popcorn.
I don't know what that, bro, so, I think, I don't know,
where do you open?
I'm pretty sure it's the brain, right?
It's the brain.
I see it.
I see the hash.
It's literally where the brain is.
So I assume, how do I get the rest of the pop?
I assume like the brain is like the pop, like the hole where
you put the popcorn in.
You can see it, yeah?
It's the pop.
Crown me the mix.
Does it take to get to the center of the popcorn?
I just thought that was really funny.
funny and I really wanted to show you guys that's really it
that's why I brought this topic up like I just have like
check out this dude check this out dragons the liquors
popcorn because I find the tweet I don't know if there's
anything else for the special collaboration I just remember
seeing that and I was like oh my god wait until I show the
dragons this if anyone is there at Universal Japan around
the time of the collaboration I bet I mean I'm pretty sure
you guys gonna have to like like two to three hours till you
get your pop it is the brain it oh that's so weird that
that's weird look at this that's so weird and the comments
is like i'm gonna cry
all right here's some here's some close-ups guys oh my god
the teeth is like individually modeled to like look at it
i'm so i'm uncomfortable i'm a little uncomfortable looking
at that not gonna lie i'm you get it all the way down to the
mouth for the popcorn hatch so open doug thank you in the
super chat thank you thank you i don't know the way he just
looks at me uh is all i can think is popcorn i don't know i
think just the way he's oh wait wait okay This is cool.
Wait, actually, I see the vision, though.
Wait, actually, this is pretty sick.
This is how you're supposed to wear it.
Let me see how you can grab a snapshot.
Wait, I get it now.
So it's like your back is like the ceiling.
Because this is how you're supposed to wear it, too.
Let me save this.
Yeah, so like you can wear your popcorn bucket as like a
backpack.
it i see the vision wait he's looking your butt he's looking
your booty hole
i see it i see the vision he's gonna touch your butt he's
toky hey hey that's what they want not me not me i just see
their vision of the popcorn bucket it's kind of cute get
yourself a popcorn bucket that wants to lick your booty hole
what's that tongue doing all right i'm gonna go get refill
my water and then and then we'll play only mooshah for real
this time um when did i adjust my sound settings for last
time i'll make sure i don't have to save the sound settings
for oh it was for don't need to save that all right let me
see let me make sure my sound settings are adjusted
correctly um okay 5.4 all right yeah leave that on screen
sure i'll leave that on screen for you guys i'm gonna get
water real quick guys i'll be right back
whoops i'm back i'm back guys sorry i didn't realize i
forgot i was muted uh all right it's gaming time lots of So
sorry, I think this might be the longest Yab session we've
done.
But I was gone for, like, an extra day.
And there was a lot of life updates going on around the
world the last couple of days.
A lot of stuff was going on.
So I had to update you guys on very important things.
Like how we're putting, we're making a fly, a virtual fly,
play Beatsaber, trapped in this eternal damnation for all of
eternity.
Yeah, some fun facts today.
Joel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Jokey, it's time to cut demons and have me.
I have a happy birthday.
Congrats, please.
Today's my birthday.
I want my favorite Dio Dio, Jokey, Dolores Bird to
congratulate me on this day.
Of course!
Joel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We have a great birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Joel.
Yeah!
Happy birthday.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just got here.
How much of the game that I missed.
Oh, I just finished it, Rice.
Oh my gosh.
You missed out.
I just finished it for the day.
Oh my, you should have seen I first tried like four bosses.
So that's why.
But you know what?
Since you're here, I'll play a little longer, Rice.
I'll play a little longer for you.
I just closed the game, but for you, just so you know, how
special you are i'll play a little bit longer yeah you
missed out on i don't think i can replicate it again though
guys i i i don't think i can replicate that again so i'm
sorry i said you missed out on some um on like some very
gamer moments for me that i could never repeat again Well,
wait, actually, that sounded bad.
I did not...
Some high-octane...
I meant high-octane gameplay.
I mean, some high-octane gameplay that I can't replicate.
That's what I meant.
Yeah, you missed my no-hit run.
No hit, no damage, no health, no items.
And I basically did that for like four to five bosses
straight So sadly you missed out you missed out and then I
and then no clipper is gonna clip it because I made
everybody Promise to not clip it just so like you'll never
see it rice because I hey guys rice missed out Make sure to
never clip that moment and I want to make sure I private the
stream and edit it out So you'll never see that happen.
Yeah, I made everybody sign an NDA shows there tells tells
them about what happened during that part when i was playing
uh you were gonna my lawyers will see you in court yeah also
i told everybody to block you too so so any you'll never see
any of the screenshots too
and yeah true i was the nda i was I'm their lawyer.
I was there.
Alright, let's play Onimusha.
Way of the Sword.
Part 2.
I just got it.
How much rice snack did I have?
It's quite a lot.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
It just had to be there.
That's on you.
Make sure you're never late again, I guess.
That's what you get for being late.
All right, let me see.
Up, up, up.
Onimusha.
All right.
Yeah, I was playing blindfolded, too.
I was like, guys, watch this.
I was like, you know what?
This game is getting too easy.
Watch this.
I put on the blindfold, and everyone started clapping.
Everyone got up and clap.
Okay, this is actually part three.
The second stream.
Golden Helm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You were actually in a coma, rice.
Like, this is hard.
This is a dream.
Wake up.
Actually, I don't want to fuck with you guys too much.
Actually, some people would actually believe that.
Like, you were actually in a coma.
Wake up.
Your family missed you.
It's true.
I was in the walls.
actually a virtual fly in the simulation cursed to play beat
saver for the rest of your life to see you back
there's far less malice hanging around than before you've
done well musashi took a lot longer than i expected took you
as a go my dream right thank you and your master of the
gauntlet is improving shizuka he's a achieved much to come
this far.
Do you think he's ready to hear about what we spoke of
earlier?
Masashi, there's more strength hidden in that gauntlet than
you may realize.
Oh shit, how do I do this?
Oh wait, I remember.
I was like, fuck, what were all the controls?
Apparently there's more moves that haven't unlocked yet.
I was like, how is there more?
Also, I realize he looks like Markiplier.
You just think, let me look at his He looks...
He sort of looks like Markiplier.
Please take note of them.
But wait, there's more...
I think Okuni had something to talk to you about as well.
Go and see her before you set off.
No, I swear to God, he looks...
He has like...
Like, he sort of looks like Markiplier at a certain angle.
I swear, I'll show you the angle.
When we're there, I'll be like, look!
There it is!
It's a team special allows you to know enhance your
equipment your marker on your map and can be revealed um
with only vision fuck how do i do only vision fuck okay guys
i actually don't remember how i do only vision oh shit where
am i okay there's an only portal i will go there okay l2 r2
guys there's so many moves and then there's gotta be more oh
wait i need to remember okay dual wielding my strat it's
okay we don't need training i got the strat i got dual
wielding watch this oh they're dancing
That's not a headshot.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, guys, guys, guys, it's been a...
There we go.
You made me use my sword!
Right on target.
Nice.
No way.
Oh, fuck.
That's fine.
There we go.
Guys, it's been a while.
It's been a while, guys, since I've dual-wheeled.
Jeez, watch.
Guys, guys, it's just been a while.
Alright, I feel this way.
Alright, I gotta go to the portal.
I assume, like, the more we clean up, the more the villages
are gonna be, like, less dangerous.
my people's power should be nearby try searching the area
all right destination reached it's in here hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to feudal japan now okay
wait wait if you look at him like
like like there's a specific angle where i'm like that's
markiplier that's like the markiplier it's like okay it's in
the cut it's like it's harder to do it here but it's in the
the cutscene.
It's in the cutscene where it looks like him.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
You see it?
You see it, right?
Yeah, I photoshopped the glasses on, and then you'll all see
it.
It's the side.
It's literally the side.
Okay.
What the fuck am I?
Why can't I climb?
Why can't you climb?
You can do everything else except climb.
This hole is your hole.
It's made for you.
Wait, is there a boat?
Oh, shit.
Thank you, backseating.
I didn't even see the loft.
Oh my god, if I can just do that, I can just climb through
the hole.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you close your eyes, it does look like Mark in my head.
Now, apparently there's some thieves around town, but
there's those need to wear eyes.
I've already mastered this handy gauntlet.
The power source seems to be hidden deep underground.
Oh, is it in the well?
I guess it's in the well.
Go on.
Try using the power of the ornate to search the area.
I want to make sure I open this door so I don't have to
worry about it.
here, but that could go here.
It might be down here, honestly.
How did I fucking hurt myself?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Ooh.
What is this portal?
Wait, I wanted to adjust the sound.
I realized, like, the sound is a little...
The sound effects is... I don't know if I did it already, so
let me double check.
Put it here.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know.
I don't know if sound guy is here, but like, I adjusted it
because I felt like the sound effects was a little bit too
loud.
So I don't know if it's better now.
Did I do it?
Oh, wait.
I can do this.
Alright.
Go into it.
Get ready.
Flashbang!
Alright.
Surprises me every time.
This place Looks familiar.
Back at Kiyomizudera temple.
This is a place of respite for Oni in the living world.
It also grants power to Onimusha.
What does it do?
Kind of power.
I wonder if there are any enemies here.
You're blowing my nose, too.
Let me double check something.
Alright.
Here we go.
So what is our core and objective to be cool?
To be a cool samurai.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
What did I miss?
Oh, that hole's gone.
So we go this way.
It's like a little parkour puzzle.
Okay.
Assume that's where I have to go.
Oh.
Why would we find one here?
What?
What is this?
This is catastrophic.
A woman?
Power has corrupted that man completely.
Oh, shit.
This is...
a memory of the distant past.
Which mean this woman is your mom oh how did this happen
minamoto no you were such a sweet boy
assume she was like part of a clan yeah that woman why is
she vague posting right that's all she does she always just
vague post are you too scared to tell us the story what are
you little boys scared
okay unlocking new visiting allows you for your strength and
your skills oh okay you've attained new strength nice how
does it feel everybody big post these days i don't really
feel any scared to say something big boy yeah it's good this
is she's a guy it's pretty cringe i shall let you know all
right let's see oh my god there's another one i'm here did i
set did i do this one already i must have right i mean i
could do this and then uh
did i do that okay i guess patching up the pouch i don't
know what that is i'll just do it for the sake of doing it
is there anything important here all right yeah i'm gonna go
for this and then tp out
okay worry about people are gonna find out okay i gotta go
to the mirror i actually sort of forgot like oh yeah i was
gonna say what am i what am i doing here
my purpose just wanted to get the godlet off of me yeah that
was my entire purpose i wanted to get the godlet off of me i
believe you can reach yet greater height um that horsuki
pouch i gave you what was the main what's my main i've been
so i've been like doing so many side quests that i actually
forgot what the main quest line was bro just cut off the art
exactly bro it's If you want it out that badly, just cut off
your arm.
Clearly you're not, you don't want it that badly.
You could, so?
I'm just out here fucking killing demons.
That's all I know.
At first I was just making my own clothes, and then I got
into making the costumes for my troop.
After a while, I kind of started enjoying it.
I guess you could call it a hobby.
Anyway, I got talking to Shizuka about all of that, and she
let me have her personal...
sewing kit oh that's sweet okay
cool right with that i just know i'm supposed to like help
my wife i bet i could make that whole uh super strong and
figure out why oh why the gauntlet yeah why the gauntlet
yeah i know why he can't remove it because he'll fucking
just fall apart like a pile of meat and flesh chisica said
one of those hiding spots isn't all 10 but like how do we
know he's telling the truth We gotta find out to figure it
out.
Yeah, see, it's right.
It's like, if he has glasses right now, if he has glasses
right now, right here, right?
I'm curious what the materials are like.
So let me know as soon as you find something.
He's gotta test that theory out, you know.
How would he know unless, like, you know, he might be
gaslighting him, you know?
It could be gaslighting him right now.
Hey.
Good luck.
Alright, let's see.
Let's grab.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, is that new?
Oh, I think it's like new...
New things to train.
Ring bell.
There is some new upgrades, but I don't know if I have
enough materials for it.
Well, I will after this.
I'm pretty sure.
ready to get to it uh yeah blazing strength and only
strength blazing stay in only strength let's get started
you're dead oh god um but just before being hit while in
blazing and you prove very effective against many's attack
will also generate more blue souls uh let's see
major stamina Okay, so I'm...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
He's doing the fucking...
No!
Okay.
All right.
Let me try this again.
No!
Okay, there it's fine.
Okay, we have one more.
Oh, my God.
Okay, all right.
It's fine.
Um, and God, we're supposed to be parrying.
All right.
Okay.
Do it.
Oh my god, bitch!
We're supposed to be carrying!
Wait.
This is my tutorial, not yours!
There we go.
God,
fuck you.
Fuck this.
I'm ending this.
here you bitch okay there you go they're supposed to be my
training grounds not yours do the thing that sense they told
you to do like give him a break he's practicing too let's
get started if he was trying to give me a hand he'll be
doing the one thing That's that he was telling me to learn
Constructions unclear I'm gonna grab him
I mean all these dudes defeat them They didn't say how Where
did this guy come from What the fuck I like how that's like
a sumo move too I just noticed that I'm still I'm still dual
wielding every time I use the arrow
X Y X you took you're supposed to X Y X Y instead of X X
instructions unclear so more X
All right, I go back
I'm not gonna kill yes, I have to kill all the bosses to
unlock anything like there's no point.
That's a waste of my time They don't give me anything, too.
It's just like, what's the word?
It's just like to brag about it.
I don't even get anything out of it.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, I don't have anything.
I'm broke.
Wait.
Oh, I increased him out of enemy stamina.
Yeah, it's just bragging rights.
Uh...
Flatter sprint speed increases.
Okay, I can't upgrade any of these yet.
Oh shit, what?
What the fuck?
I can just throw a tree at them?
Yeah, fuck yeah.
Let me fucking chuck a China's tree.
Okay, that's everything.
it was already corrupted anyway so we're it's fine all right
we got to go okay patching up the pouch all right
all right there's a giant there's a flying pig here
you'll just fuel for the gauntlets what the oh okay that's
fine all
right whatever i i thought i thought i could get a cool some
shit cool guys don't look at deflections apparently this is
the temple okuni told you about we should begin our search
all right we'll go right side first okay never mind we'll go
forward look at that look at that fruit pears pears for days
fun vault think of a super chat thingy thing but oh I can't
pick it up because no no guy gave it to me
What the fuck is that Those brains what the fuck is that?
They're like crawling brains Oh shit, okay.
Oh now I can kill it.
Oh, it's like a It's like those like alien parasite things
disgusting
oh now now it hurts me see this way i tried pre-kill it
hello what's going on just now yeah what was that i am
unsure oh my god did they take yeah those like face huggers
are they gonna take off oh my god are the face huggers gonna
take over the fucking dead bodies and then it's like round
two is that it is that did i just write the game it out the
enemy mechanics?
Oh, why are there face huggers?
Is it not for hugging some faces?
No way.
Surely that can't possibly be it.
Is this dead space?
This is dead space, isn't it?
Oh, I fucking knew it.
Get your hands off me.
I fucking knew it.
All these pile of bodies I wonder what they're for!
Is this guy a Gamma-2?
Yes, a parasitic Gamma variant.
Alright.
Oh, what the fuck?
He deflects me!
I did not need to do that.
I just want to prove a point.
Alright, here we go.
Wow, I wonder what that is.
That parasite?
Oh, shit, this is bad.
Oh my god, it's Resident Evil 2.
Oh my god, oh my god, it's him!
He's...
Clean in two.
That should be the last.
Uh...
What did you take?
from me.
That's one way of putting it.
And it's dead space resident evil.
And alien.
Alright.
Yeah, these residents do look a little evil.
That has to be, yeah, flammable.
Someone's gonna show up top there.
Fucking knew it.
Hey.
there you go it's fine i mean it's fine like what oh my god
he sucks my soul it is no longer fine
even run from that oh my god it's no longer fine oh my god i
thought i could run there
i have to do this
All right, we actually have to use this
All right, this is not fair.
Oh my god Oh my god, and they suck my souls too.
That's it
Oh my god, that's not what I wanted take this
Why they better have like a lot of fucking souls inside them
afterwards Well done.
Alright.
Here we go.
Get deflected!
Alright.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Alright.
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
That's it.
I'll cut you out.
Let's strike.
Alright, there you go.
Holy shit.
Okay, that has to be the most annoying enemy so far.
That was definitely the most annoying one.
Yeah, I thought it was like...
I saw something there, but I guess not.
Oh, crap.
That's so far.
Yeah, that's what I said!
I know!
I know it can only go get worse.
We must be close.
I know it can only get worse, guys.
And I can, like, headshot them, like, Resident Evil, too.
I can get Resident Evil, too.
Alright.
Found something.
Only club.
This is what we were after.
It certainly is.
The dokey is going to get way worse.
Ha ha!
Yeah, oh, wee!
I think the worst part is the fact that I can't headshot
them.
I can't abuse that.
There's like a treasure here.
How do I get there, though?
I'm going to try and see, figure this out.
Okay, there are stuff I haven't got yet.
okay through here there are some hidden items oh it's here
you just leave me like that for me to take for free no traps
i'll go to it this feels suspicious that there's no traps
here i don't like it i don't like that just like got it for
free without any struggle or anything they figured it out
they know your one strat how did they figure it out my one
my one strat i've been using the entire time how did they
know they're stream sniping how did they figure it out
don't understand I think the game caught Onimusha, the way
of a sword.
What's you that use a sword, Doki?
You don't know that.
They just couldn't fit sword and bow because they were out
of characters.
It was past...
They had a character limit.
The bow was implied.
It was implied.
Can you like
Press X after successful Reflex dodge
Okay I feel like I need two power stones for this The way of
the bow I think it's a better title too Something up Found
what we're looking for Oh nice work Let's see wow this is
what only materials are like no no falling in love with the
merchandise materials are for using give me a moment okay oh
okay so my healing is a lot stronger now shiny new hosuki
pouch nice that's good with the right you can hold a to
enhance a pouch enhance the pouch to carry more hosuki you
can doing this up to three times all right nice serious with
various effects find only artifacts and hand into oh to
unlock new what would be better than heels though you're
really good at that huh yeah this was nothing if you find
any more i do see marco i told you it's like a particular
angle and during cutscenes it takes care of it's like there
how's your hosuke pouch All right.
I'm pretty sure someone's doing a bow-only run.
It's like how in...
All right, let's grab this.
It's like how in any Souls-like game, people would do like
the craziest challenges, no matter, like, it doesn't matter
what challenge you're doing.
It's like the one with, like...
What's the one that they beat, like, Elden Ring with their
fucking brain?
That shit was wild.
What's the craziest one?
I think the brain one was the craziest one I've seen.
Yeah, like with their brainwaves.
They literally beat Elden Ring with their brainwaves.
That shit was wild.
Oh yeah, there's one where they made a goldfish play Elden
Ring too.
Yeah, I saw that one.
That one's crazy too.
You're just fuel for the gold.
What?
That was an instant?
Oh shit, that guy was...
What is he gonna do?
Slowly walk up to me?
Oh my god, his eyes are boobs.
Did you notice that?
His eyes just became boobs.
Score a hundred headshots with your bow.
That's me.
Where?
Oh, I didn't even see this guy.
Oh, you saw that today.
Oh, that's me.
Wait, I can open that door.
There.
Alright, get over here.
Alright, it's just easier if they're closer.
Here it comes.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Alright, more shots doesn't mean more hits.
Buddy.
Surely if I shoot seven arrows, one of them will hit.
He stays as I walk to the side.
That's why...
Okay, that's also why I like using the bow.
Because it's so satisfying.
Hitting those shots.
It's actually so satisfying.
Like, what is he doing?
He got a lot.
Alright, there we go.
Nice.
The secret technique.
There we go.
Open this real quick.
Someone on the other side.
Knock, knock!
Who's gonna punish me?
What the fuck?
Well, that was a scare, bro.
Small fry.
Oh shit, he wore a hat!
Oh my god, Adora's hat!
My only counter!
A helmet!
Actually my only counter.
Who would have thought?
Alright.
What the fuck are you gonna do?
Walk?
Walk up to me?
Or fly up to me?
It's not a threat.
Wait a minute, does it know?
He's walking over there.
Yeah, all his friends are dead.
There you go.
Just that easy.
Oh, that's the pouch.
There you go.
I like that glows too.
Nice, a half pair.
Well, I've always wanted.
I can't believe they figured out my one weakness a fucking
helmet no no one thing that can counter me oh shit oh my god
what the fuck was that on your god
oh my god oh my god it's too many things I'm afraid!
Do I have to kill these guys first?
Oh my god, there's a lot of things dealing with fire?
Evade?
Oh shit, okay.
I'm on burning, I'm burning, I'm burning.
I'm burning right now.
Boom!
I need to heal anyway.
Okay.
All right.
That's to kill you.
You're all dead.
That's fucking right!
Get buried!
Is that all you've got?
Oh my god, thank god I...
Thank god I killed him before he can do anything else.
And then last headshot.
For the ride.
Oh, thank god I saw the explosion in time.
Oh, there's another explosion, too.
That's good.
I have an extra...
Oh my god, there's so many explosions.
Alright, I opened another door.
Yeah, huh.
It's all natural alarms.
No worries or anything.
Okay, that'll go this way.
I missed anything?
No, right?
I shouldn't think I got everything.
Oh, there's so many, like, hidden doors everywhere.
Oh, oh, there it is.
Okay, let's open this first before anything.
Oh, what did I get here?
What did I got?
Got a nice find.
No, there was a portal.
Yeah.
There's another hidden chest.
A chest within a chest.
The only claw.
There's more?
Where is this?
Tokuni.
I missed a chest back there.
Oh shit, I didn't see you guys.
Oh, whoops.
Catching fire when oil is so too reset me and you burn.
You'll just fuel for the gauntlets.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, shit, I don't think he liked it.
He definitely did not like that I threw a wound that broke
his thing.
Okay, I broke.
Okay, that should be headshots.
Okay, now I can do headshots.
Okay, that's good.
They're slowly back you.
Yeah!
I'm out of the pathway!
it's like he's like oh I don't want to go past there that's
dangerous it's dangerous over there I don't it's scared
there's like this part this side isn't gentrified let us
continue like I heard that's the I heard that's the bad part
of the neighborhood we shouldn't go there
something here.
Wait, how do I get across from here again?
Hello?
I had to crawl in there, right?
Oh, yeah, it's here.
I forgot it was a hole.
There we go.
Your secret?
It says destination reach.
How the... Oh, it's on the other side.
Wait, can I fall from this side, though?
How the fuck?
That's weird.
Is there a ladder anywhere?
Huh.
Okay, so I have to fall somewhere from that side, but how?
Should I order ladders for me to get there?
I'm gonna try this one.
That chest is over there.
Can you jump No, apparently a samurai doesn't jump.
It'll hurt his little delicate legs.
What the fuck do I get there?
Is there a hole there that I missed?
I'm going to try for the other chest.
Okay, so I can't do...
Oh, I missed this one.
Yeah, he has very delicate legs, guys.
Guys, he spent all of his money on arm enhancements.
Not leg enhancements.
Yo, Trevor, this chest.
Maybe here?
No?
Oh my god.
I just want to grab loot.
Because loot equals up.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, so we figured that here...
There we go.
Got that.
We got Oni Stone.
Like these chests are actually really good only because of
the power-ups.
Like I want them for power-ups.
There's a lot of stuff I need to upgrade.
That'll be good for me long term.
Here?
now what oh my god it's like oh my god that's so cheeky
that's so fucking cheeky I like next door is like guys
perfectly safe nothing to worry about nice there's a shrine
here oh fuck
it might as well since I have enough anyway
Uh...
Oh, there's one more.
I missed that one.
My marker taking me.
I'm gonna go to the bad part of the town.
I ain't afraid.
This way.
I don't have any new enemies spawn in after that.
Alright, this way.
Oh wait, they do spawn back in.
Fuck, I forgot.
that.
All right.
Impressive bow technique.
Thank you.
Thank God for Onimusha Way of the Bow.
I love Onimusha Way of the Bow.
I just think it's faster, guys.
Is that someone hiding?
No, he's just a dead man.
I just think it's faster.
It's just convenient.
Like the headshot is one hit, one kill.
Whoops.
And it's more size.
Exactly.
I know I keep saying, but it is more...
more satisfying.
Here we are, go.
If they didn't want me to use the boat, they shouldn't have
giving it to me.
That's on them.
That's on them for giving me a boat.
Okay, that's it.
I should...
Oh, I should...
I thought I took this mission, but I guess not.
Yeah, if they didn't want me to use a boat, they would have
given...
Exactly.
They could have given me an ammo limit.
That's on them for not nerfing me.
Oh, health and stamina.
Regenerate with time.
I don't know if I like that.
Is this good at all?
Which is better.
For those who played it already.
Regeneration or a default?
Because it's slow.
That's the issue.
Emergency patch incoming.
Gamer was not playing my game correctly.
So we patched it up.
Specifically a weird one.
And like specifically Doki Bird.
Is it matter of taste?
Stamina is...
Default is better.
I'll just keep Default.
Oh, it forces me to try it.
For tutorial.
Got it.
I'm just going to use D-Fuck.
It's easier to use.
Not playing the game as intended.
We have to side and patch the bow out.
Right.
I need to grab this mission.
Is this...
Whoops.
Alright.
I just want to know which way is faster.
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh, it was the berry.
I don't need a berry.
I'm full HP now.
It's just chilling there.
He's just enjoying the scenery.
Oh my god.
Nice.
He's like, today's such a beautiful day.
Wow.
I should visit mom.
I should...
You know what?
Good thing.
Good thing they told me they go out today.
It's such a beautiful day.
Whoops, did not mean to do that, but that's fine.
What?
Oh, I hear stuff inside there.
Oh, this is the Pale Lights mission.
I thought it was like, mission I haven't done yet.
Grab this real quick.
Wait, what a beautiful...
Beautiful day to touch grass.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen to me.
See, I read my astrologies.
Oh, today.
So I'm gonna have...
Whoa.
Whoa!
Astrologists said that, like, I'm gonna be a big hit today.
With all my friends.
They're gonna go crazy that I might even lose my head you
guys shoot on the side i shoot his feet feet cannot shoot
feet guys
that while he's getting up holy shit there's like a beat box
going on in there
people are beatboxing what's going on here yeah oh shit
Shining Vim
It's fine I didn't shoot all of this Oh, I didn't see this
one guy All right, whoa whoa whoops I hope they didn't see
me Okay, I thought I could carry it not gonna last I didn't
realize it's like Like, wherever you're aiming at is where
it's gonna go.
See, look at that.
It took me three hits, but you know what takes me two shots?
Let's go.
Can I even aim that over there?
Oh.
Oh my god, you literally didn't see that.
Wait, I'm gonna suck that real quick.
Where is he?
There you go.
that's okay bamboo actually grows surprisingly really really
fast they like grow over a net oh all right now that's three
shots only because i missed one shot i didn't charge it up
all right we got the soul sucker and we got some extra items
some bonus items along the ride too thank god i'll take that
thank god all these people are dead so no one can claim it
all right we gotta go here and then do that take the mirror
go up here grab this pouch and then go straight down we have
a path we set up a path oh they're having so much fun out
this i I wonder what they're doing.
Banner's keepers.
Is that an item?
Oh, shit.
That is an item.
I bet that's where his head is.
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
It's not wearing a helmet anymore.
Okay, it's actually so much easier to kill them via bow than
sword.
Oh, he's going to suck that, isn't he?
Not if I suck it first.
Wait, did he run away?
Scared of dark, little boy.
Wait, actually...
Yeah, it took me two slashes for that timey little damage.
That watermelon that's been contaminated.
By all these bodily fluids.
Ah, yes!
I love getting watermelon exposed with all the guts and
gore.
My favorite!
My favorite seasoning
Yeah, why use a sword when you can have two bows?
That's what I'm saying
Why even give me a sword anyway?
Oh my god Oops, okay, I got the two over coffin in there.
Look at look how many how many swipes it takes me Why can't
I just upgrade my my bow and
Look at that.
You counted that?
Seven slashes.
I'm going to have to do better than that.
Doki, what about three?
Ooh.
Ooh, now you're thinking with bows.
Yeah, I don't like how there's so many jars here.
It has to be...
Oh, yeah, I have friend.
Because I never grew up with Legend of Zelda.
at all like i never played like i told you guys how the only
i knew it i knew there was one that was hiding in that
little jar so and then um um because i never grew up with a
like i never really grew up with like nintendo consoles
other than uh like the handheld stuff and then so um yeah
i'm oh yeah i know i saw the what was it it was the ocarina
of time the leaks for ocarina of time and Like, not happy
about it.
Dude, there is something about it that was, like, a little
uncanny.
Yeah, the remake looked, the graphics for the remake look a
little uncanny, not gonna lie.
Anyway, so, my friend was trying to explain the lore, like,
because, like, Ledger Zelda to me, but, like, they were very
confused as well.
So like they got confused with the lore and they were like
Because I was like, yeah They're like, you know the story of
Legend of Zelda And I was like, yeah, like they're always
like reincarnate Or like something like how like There are
like multiple alternate universes Or timelines of Link and
Zelda And then they were like Yeah, yeah, so like every time
So okay, so they got They were confused with the lore of
Legend of Zelda At first because like that fuck That made me
more confused views and they're like yeah so um so no matter
what link and Zelda will always get married and have kids
together and their kids will some event then their
descendants will eventually become link and Zelda and I was
like wait so incest like so I was like wait so like that's
just incest like because if that's so related and I was like
that can't be right I was like to my friend I was That can't
be right.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
I was like, what do you mean?
Like, their kids will live.
Like, their kids, kids will live.
Like, the royal bloodline.
Are we talking about, like, the royal bloodline here?
And...
So I got really confused.
And then they were like, wait, now that you said that
doesn't actually sound right?
I was like, yeah, no, fucking shit.
That doesn't sound right.
so beautiful i'm so certain it was them oh hell uh look
there's no such thing as moon okay and stay away from things
you don't understand and don't want to get yourself killed
what do you mean no such thing if ghost and goblin exist
existent why can't moon folk tell him because that's wrong
there anything it was to reach out to you thank you lies up
to you in stairs for my big old eyes get shot perhaps we can
discuss this again some other time in any event thank you
for getting to the bottom these mysterious going on so yeah
i was just like i was like are you i was just like that
doesn't sound right like so i'm good so they had to like
double rewatch the lore video they rewatched the lore video
or some shit and then came back like wait wait you're right
I was like, yeah, because if they're, like, their ancestors
eventually reincarnate into Link and Zelda, that's just
incest.
Like, so I was like, I think you should fact check your
lore, because that doesn't make sense at all.
Why?
That's just the royal bloodline.
That's just a monarchy.
Um, what do I actually feel?
Okay, I'm so bad at that.
I'm just going to get...
I'm just getting...
I'm just going to beef up my bow.
I...
If it works, it works, guys.
Get reflex combo, please, you...
Whoops, too late.
Whoops.
Bow only run.
all right let's see we want to grab okay
what only stone that we never used I'm gonna grab this I
don't keep thinking mad the duration speed like I doesn't
matter not gonna like this does not matter to me so I rather
use it for only for
treasures oh yeah I was gonna let's actually progress the
Lord we've done a lot Oh, unless we get this!
There is a pouch up there.
Uh...
This way.
It appears the malice around Kenyanji Temple has thinned.
Oh, it has.
I don't think we did anything.
What's that over there?
Aren't you destroyed on the slope?
Oh, is there any items there?
Nah, it doesn't matter.
That doesn't matter.
Oh my god, I can throw the tree!
Whoops.
It's so strong.
Oh my god.
Wait, how strong?
How much damage?
No!
Whoops.
Okay, nice, nice.
You hurt yourself and confuse it.
Confusion.
Good, that's what we needed.
You're hurting something, Confusion!
That's right!
Are you even trying?
Okay, let's grab this tree real quick.
Just for you.
All right.
I wonder if the next upgrade it can charge even faster.
How do I get there?
Oh, it says here.
Is that door...
Can I open this?
No, I can.
How do I get up there?
Wait, is it in the malice?
Oh, my God.
It's in the malice, isn't it?
Yeah.
Can't even get up.
Oh, my.
I was lied to.
I thought I could get up there.
I will just do that, then.
It baited me.
It looked so climbable.
Fuck is that Didn't get rid of this guy Oh my god how do you
know How do you know
He doesn't know Just fuel for the gauntlets
I don't need my sword I don't take it Surely there's an
upgrade where I can charge this up Oh
It's fine.
I suck up all of this.
I think that's...
Is that a chest?
I knew it.
I was like, what are they guarding?
Okay, I like how...
Okay.
I pressed!
Oh my god, nice, nice, nice.
There you go.
Carried!
What?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
See?
I can parry.
Die faster so I can take your souls.
See, guys?
I can parry.
It's not just all bow and ball game, guys.
It's not just ball and bow game.
It's There you go.
Got a little too excited there.
Fucking self-destruct.
It was bow and ball.
I like how this area is just an empty.
Just an empty road leading to nothing.
Oh.
There he is.
How many shots can you get in?
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I want to get rid of...
I'm going to get rid of this guy first.
Actually, I need...
I need HP.
Alright, I actually needed that too.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
No, fuck!
Why didn't I get reflex combo?
Oh my god.
Don't be good right now.
Reflex combo.
Really?
Was that all you got?
Alright.
I'm gonna grab kills too.
Should be loot here, right?
There's a lot of people guarding this area.
Did I loot this area already?
Can't tell.
Let me just...
Destination reached.
It's, like, next door.
How the fuck did it make me go here when there's nothing
here?
Are you serious?
There was no loot here.
I must have looted this place already.
There's, like, literally nothing here.
What do you mean, destination reached?
I'm not even there yet.
I don't want to activate anything yet.
Let's get these guys out of here.
Does anybody...
Looks like a Vichy helmet.
I'm too part of rubbish here.
Let's get cleaning.
Alright.
Fucking knew it.
Oh, he's alive.
Alright, I can...
I can splash this.
I knew I could start...
Oh my god!
Okay, see, see, I can't ease in.
Okay, that's bullshit.
Oh my god.
You're so, that's me.
One strike.
That's right.
Sometimes three strikes.
Look at that.
Ah!
Where did y'all come from?
Holy shoot, we got a lot more than I thought.
Okay, I did not realize there were 20 of these.
Made the hate!
You bitch!
That's why I use both.
Fuck this.
This is exactly why I use both.
That's it.
It's fine.
One at a time.
I know you don't want to go to the bad neighborhood.
There you go.
Let us return and tell him.
Alright, I got through.
Oh my god, that's a tree.
That's a tree.
I could have used the tree the entire time.
I thought it was decorate.
I thought.
Okay, whatever.
It's fine.
I hear that I'm on the...
I'm just gonna heal up.
It's fine.
I'm wearing a shirt.
Enhance.
All right, now it should be a level two.
Yeah, the Easton was cool, at least.
When did they show up again?
No, it was a one-time thing, thank God.
All right, now we've progressed the main plot.
Finally here.
After an hour, we can finally progress the storyline.
Australian?
He's picking a bite?
Hell yeah, brother.
Oh, he's based on Australian.
All the way from the temple's Dharma Hall, I believe.
They surely belong to the Gemma occupying this place.
Don't worry.
They will be occupied if they want.
Oh, yes, of course the Australians are demons.
Oh, my God.
They're going to 2v1 me.
Is that what's gonna happen?
Is this a 2v1?
Alright.
Oh, there's items here I missed out on.
Okay.
That's it.
Oh, it's worth it!
It's worth it!
It was worth it!
Ah, shit!
Get this out of the way.
What the fuck?
I mean, sure.
I take those.
That's fucking right.
Well done.
I think you could have won that twice.
Yeah, probably.
See, guys, I can learn.
All right.
My first boss fight of the day.
Do these things have any purpose in life other than to get
in my way?
It should be all of them.
That's how it's done.
A masterful display.
Spider.
Where's the spider?
Whoops.
There's two.
I'll go to the one on the left.
It's already cleared it up.
That is well.
Oh.
Is he looking at me or looking behind me?
I can't...
Oh wait, he's definitely looking at me.
God,
I'm so close.
Oh.
There you go.
That's right!
Get burned!
Boom!
Oh!
Oh, yeah, look at that.
No hit.
No hit run.
Right here.
No hit.
He's not even guarding any... Oh.
He was guarding something.
Oh, a secret?
Secret?
Secret tunnel?
I knew it.
There's always a secret.
Find his keepers.
I could feel the secret calling for me.
It should be around here, right?
On the other side.
Wait, what?
Oh, I guess that was just secret.
There's nothing else.
Oh, okay.
That understood.
I have no food.
I have no food, guys.
He's just doing it for attention now.
Okay.
I can't do that because it's like on it's over here.
Oh, I have to go up.
Oh my god I recommend it.
It's been fun.
This game has been fun.
If you like souls like game, I like this this is the hardest
souls like game I've ever played for sure
And that's like me like I think it is like literally just
like
And the reason why it's so hard for me too is because
there's so many different ways you can block like this.
Oh my god.
Like timing is so important!
Victory is us.
Yeah and it gets harder too.
There's like definitely...
If you guys, if you like a challenge, you like...
I think even if it's so hard, I still enjoy this game.
Even if it's like particularly difficult for me.
There it is.
What?
Damn, that's far.
Yeah.
I fear the bow.
Maybe you're in the option.
Oh, it's here.
I see it.
What to go?
Not bad.
Was there a pouch here?
I don't remember where I missed the pouch.
Who the hell asked you?
Mouthy gunma fucks.
Damn!
Just because you're Australian?
Alright.
Maybe I missed the bow here.
What is it?
Oh, there it is.
Did I even shoot through that?
Did I shoot it?
No.
I don't know if I shoot that one then.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I figured it out, guys.
Alright.
I didn't realize it was a ledge.
You're here.
Thought you'd have run away by now.
Who's running?
You ain't right there.
I'm gonna gut you both
All right, here we go.
I'm a little worried I found out guys, I just that's hard
because he can't jump so I don't know what he can and can't
do when it comes to ledges
Is it like I think it's a lot.
Oh, it's like dragon is even stronger than I heard This
should be fun What are you two giggling about?
We seek one thing in life.
Good fights with bad guys?
No, I'm a good guy.
We meet every Oni in hell.
Time to meet an Oni Musha.
That means you, buddy.
But I'm a good guy.
He's so right in the distance.
Yeah.
Enough chat.
Let's battle, samurai.
Oh shit.
Oh, it's this type of...
Oh, it's in his back.
Is it his back?
Is his brother on his back?
Those giant tumor on your head.
Oh, what is your...
Okay, it's this.
Alright.
Oh, fuck!
I thought I could...
I thought I could predict it.
I don't...
I like Doki what?
Doki just...
Finally, someone worth beating.
He's dead.
Show me a good fight!
Right back at you after all that boasting and showbiting
better make this worth the trip
Try hard all right I'm gonna grab this I need HP really
badly too
Oh into the blazing state and counter attack all right I
just have to keep parrying until I get there Oh no.
It's fine.
No!
There we go.
Okay.
Are you serious?
I clicked this!
I need to eat this.
Oh my god, no!
Holy shit, this is so much.
Okay, I need to figure out the pattern for this Are you
kidding me?
No, screw!
Are you like dodged it?
I fucking dodged it!
You're dead!
They still learn things quick!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, I need to time...
I need to time that correctly.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Bitch!
Oh, I need to eat.
I don't know what that does.
No!
Alright.
Nice.
Are you serious?
I pressed X.
for it.
Oh my god.
Aim for the power to make it back.
I can't!
He's clearly camping it!
He's camping the pouch!
Oh god.
Oh my god, he's one.
He's actually... He's actually one.
Okay.
Oh, there's a phase two.
There's a phase two.
I can do it
There's always a phase two
Oh my god Oh my god I'm lost my flow I lost my flow
Are you kidding me Are you kidding me
Oh my god Okay I'm gonna see why he's barking I don't know
if he needs like water or something because he had his food
I gave him his food okay
you wanted more food I have no food to give him I have no
treats I have no more treats I there's no food dad there's
papa thank you this every chap thank you thank you there's
no food show me what you've got
Yeah Yeah, that's raising energy into your blade then you'll
be able to press the attack all right boom Boom okay
Did I do that Okay Oh my god, I got I fucked up with the
finally someone worth beating oh okay better show me a good
fight right back at you are you serious i can't i'm on the
ground you better make this worth the trip i'm literally on
the ground that's cheating there you go there you go
all right Oh my god.
There you go.
Nice.
Nice to me.
Good job, Joki.
Are you serious?
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
Here it comes!
I've never seen that move in my life.
Hey, right there.
I dodge.
I swear to God, I dodge.
You must heal quickly.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
No!
You serious!
I dodge!
I swear to God!
I swear to God I dodge.
I'm going all out!
I swear to God!
What's that?
There you see!
What is that?
Squatch!
There must be a way to drop them.
Okay.
All right.
I deflected.
Oh god!
me out from the fucking yeah they're placing energy into
your blade then you'll be able to press the attack i swear
to god i'm trying oh my god i don't know i i assume i have
to blow him i assume i have to blow him bow it blow him when
he gets there Show me what you've got!
Okay.
Oh my god, the double one.
Okay, I have to fucking lock in.
Sorry now.
Finally, someone worth beating.
Better show me a good fight!
Right back at you.
After all that boasting and showbiting.
to make this worth the trip.
Nice.
Okay, I used X.
Did I use X or Y?
Don't die!
I used both!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
I need the HP too.
Oh!
All right What that wasn't too hard you bitch
Okay, that's fine
Okay, I clicked it I clicked oh Oh my god I barely hate you
All right, it's fine Nice.
Okay, I need that.
I need that so bad.
Okay.
You're dead.
Please no, not again.
Why did...
Oh, it's too fair.
I was trying to...
You may not survive this.
No, I will!
I will, my beautiful wife!
No chance.
We just gotta believe!
My wife didn't believe!
Alright.
You stabbed me!
I can't believe it!
My wife didn't believe in me!
There we go.
First phase over.
You've really got him who's sweating.
You're all right on him, Mushar!
I can see your moves.
I'll keep the- Oh, can I?
Really?
Haha!
Let's see how- How will you fight that?
I don't know about that.
Oh my god, I can't see!
This'll end things quick.
Okay.
It's like, I can see your move.
And I was like, I can?
Here it comes!
Oh my god.
Okay Into the blazing state I just have to carry I tried
sir.
Okay, I did I did I did.
Okay, sometimes it looks like he grabbed me and sometimes I
did it Oh god At least he put me Give me time to heal
though, which is good
Nice Oh my god, it's weird to god i died we'll see you in
hell for another round every time i feel like i click it too
i feel like i clicked it and then it doesn't register oh
show me what you've got
okay all right that's five no chance okay
all right
bitch oh my god finally someone worth beating you better
show me a good fight right back at you after all that
boasting and showboating you better make this work okay
that's it I'm gonna I'm gonna use this I don't care I don't
care if I'm wasting it I'm corner trapping him Oh, but
he's...
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay.
I got that timed at least.
It's the little things!
I'll take those!
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh my god.
What the?
Are you fucking...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I timed it.
Okay.
There you go.
I got that timing in correctly at least.
oh my god blazing energy into a blade i swear to god my
beautiful wave oh my god leaving anything give me
last it last it last it you barely got him who's sweating
you're all right i wish i What?
Oh, I thought I could time that.
Oh my god, it's because of the heals.
It's because I was healing.
I'm going all out.
Get blasted!
Here we go.
I was scared.
I thought it was a tumor.
I thought it was a medical condition.
addition this will end things quick okay here you go there
you go oh eat this oh okay there you go oh i'm just trying
to survive right now
There you go.
Aim for the pouch on this back.
Oh, I got attacked.
I'm in my flow state.
Stop me.
Hey, don't twist.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Here we go.
Ah!
All right.
That's fine.
That timing, at least.
All right.
It's fine.
I got that timing in.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It's okay.
Not gonna help.
Okay.
Oh, I'm gaming.
I figured it out.
I think I figured it out.
Okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I figured it out.
Oh, you cry.
Everything's clicking now in my head.
Everything's clicking.
You just got some valleys in my eyes.
Phase three.
I can't find valleys in my eyes.
Next time.
Ah.
See?
Your command of the gauntlet's power.
Oh, I'm good?
All right, nice.
I killed his brother.
Okay.
I'm beginning to believe.
I'm beginning to believe now.
I'm beginning to believe, guys.
I'm figuring it out.
Alright, alright, alright.
I think I figured it out.
I think I got it.
I got it.
I figured it out.
I know the way.
I see it.
I see it in my head.
I'm visualizing it.
I'm... Guys, guys, I see the visuals.
I see it playing in my head.
holy fuck okay so
it just it just took me a while it took me up I figured it
out I'm sorry I don't know where's the exit where's the exit
how do I get out of here
I'm like watching in like 80 right now I'm like reading it
like I'm like 50 steps away ahead
Yeah, we gotta go this way.
And then, what can we enhance?
Alright, we enhance this.
Okay.
Alright, we'll get the reflex combo for real.
Uh, we wanna go here.
Oh my god, Snowy!
Thank you, oh, it's insane support, Snowy!
It was a gift to so many, so many memberships.
Snowy, for the 50 gifted chips, Snowy.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
The 50 bomb.
I really appreciate it, Snowy.
You've always been supporting me with so many big gifted.
I really appreciate it.
And that's my reward.
I can finally...
I see it now.
I've entered the flow state.
Everything's clicking in my head.
Let's spot Titan, your heart and soul are positively
gleaming.
I just took a few monsters.
That's all.
No big deal.
You knew they'd be there, didn't you?
Now your mind is clear, and my road home is free of danger.
You scratched my back, and I scratched yours.
A mutually advantageous agreement, wouldn't you agree?
I mean, I get free shit out of that.
More upgrades.
Oh my god.
Our own oiler.
What is this?
What do I see?
I see that, right?
It vibrates.
But what does it vibrate for?
What?
I get like, like a blue aura around me.
I wish it really cleaned that.
Where is it coming from?
Snowy, thank you again.
Thank you for supporting the dragon, Snowy.
Oh, look up.
Gamers don't look up.
Silly.
What am I supposed to look up on?
Oh, shit!
There it is.
How do I get up there?
Alright, there it is.
Oh, no, I look up.
up.
I'm no longer a gamer!
Joki has looked up.
She has revoked her gamer privilege.
Oh there it is.
I got this little secret.
All right.
Nice.
Spend my note.
I had to go back.
to the center.
Are you seeing a new phone that's like a new iPhone is going
to be a flip phone?
It's so weird.
I don't know.
I feel like it looks like it's going to be seamless, but
then I'm like, is it actually that seamless, though?
Like the folds?
How's your Horsuki pouch?
I don't know.
I'm like doubting it.
Yeah, the forable phone.
iPhone.
got rid of them cool yeah they're never that seamless that's
what i'm like i don't know if i like that so kennyji temple
stands purified consider me impressed boy
hmm actually i'm not the only one impressed an old
acquaintance of mine has been wanting to meet you demanding
in fact incessantly Would meeting them help with my gauntlet
problem?
I know none with deeper or broader knowledge, especially
when it comes to Genma.
It'll be worth your while.
Good enough reason, I guess.
Where do I find them?
Yasuka Shrine.
The road's been cut off by Malice.
You should take the Spirit Mirror.
all right right here right here okay there is what he does
that that's the markup live face right there yeah 2k for a
foldable phone i feel like there's definitely a lot cheaper
options where they like they've like refined the tech for
foldable phones you know like what is the the chinese one
the chinese brand um I'm trying to remember the name of it.
Because I know that's a very popular brand, too.
Yeah.
Huawei.
Because they've been doing foldable phones for a while now.
This must be Yasaka Shrine.
Now, where's Takamura's friend?
I sense a presence in the structure further in on the right.
Then that's where we'll go.
with all right oh hey everybody's having a good time look at
that no demons here
i'll go this way
your miyamoto masashi oh my god such a cute dog look at him
oh you guys can't see him i block him you can see his face
are you the one who are you Creepy Lady Murasaki.
Murasaki, purple lady?
Never heard of her.
Read the tale of Genji.
It's a good story.
Genji?
From Overwatch?
I wrote it.
Unfortunately, I died a few hundred years ago, but there is
just such abundant pathos of this world left to uncover.
She's not alive?
Dead or not, I simply won't leave the mortal realm with so
many tales undiscovered and untold
she is an odd one and she's a ghost have you heard there are
strange happenings at nijojo castle supposedly a mysterious
genma is on a rampage and people are going missing i have
heard of nijojo castle it's where the local army is i
definitely heard of it.
Can you like, but just so like everyone else knows, can you
explain it?
Oh, thank you, Suzuku.
This is Suzuka.
Indeed.
And Genma usually leave corpses.
If people are disappearing, to what end?
I simply must learn the truth of this oddity.
And I would call upon you, Miyamoto Musashi, to ascertain it
for me.
He's just like more side quests.
He's like, how to remove gauntlet and it's like a 80 step
program.
Like, is that even worth it at that point?
But need Jojo Castle.
They're not going to let someone else touch someone.
That's the worst part.
I know a way.
Let us return to Rocco Chimney's temple and see Gokuni's
council.
she do all
right oh nice well at least she gave me stuff look at him
it's such a cute die hey they're sleeping yeah for free
disgusting all right i can enhance the new thing now okay
now i can have stronger sword it's crazy because i don't
know what the fuck to do with that what am i gonna do with a
stronger sword guys What is this arrow?
Oh, it's blocked.
Okay.
Just doing errands all day for Ghost because they can't do
it themselves.
You need something.
Okuni, I heard you can get me into the Georgia castle.
I need to be in there right now.
Huh?
Musashi, perhaps I should do the talking.
How lost are you going to be if I didn't watch the first
stream?
basically, he died.
He now has a goblet on his arm, but the only way to get rid
of a goblet is to do errands for all these ghosts.
The end.
That's like a quick rundown of everything.
Are you famous or something?
I told you.
If you don't know anything at all about Protos is getting
here, you'd already know oh yeah ghosts and oni book for
once say that again please yeah this is a long fetch quest
for all these ghosts anyway is there yowie though there's
doom yowie leave it to me okay so she's been there several
times come on if we're going let's go like is it really that
bad to have a gauntlet though on your arm i guess because
he's like how am i gonna wash my like want the the ghost
wife attached to him 24 like he wants privacy he wants
private it makes sense i was gonna say how bad is it having
i forgot his like fucking virtual wife lives in his arm so
it makes sense that he would want some privacy you know like
sometimes it seems you've made quite a name for yourself as
a dancer i hear your troops kabuki dances the talk of the
town still nothing compared to you though shizuka and
besides done with dancing oh but why yeah what happened i
used to she's like i used to be a dancer and one of our
members is missing till it gemma did it till the onis
arrived who else and then you went to takamura for help i am
not the kind of person who goes around crying for help no
definitely that member is dead she's gone I went to Takamori
to get the power of the Oni, no matter what it costs me.
Oh, she wants the glove.
But you get it instead, and you won't stop complaining about
it.
Hey, I dedicated my life to mastering the sword, but getting
strong.
Oh, there you go.
That's not strength.
He's like, I don't need no AI to help me.
The power to defeat your enemies.
What else is there?
He's like, get this AI slop off my arm.
You know what?
If you don't want it, just cut your damn arm off and let me
have that gauntlet.
Have you lost your mind?
What's a swordsman without his arm?
Oh, that's like the pussy.
He doesn't want to chop his arm off.
You're on your own from here.
Damn, he must have been like...
Yeah, she's like, what the...
Why are we arguing?
How do we get into this argument?
Huh?
He doesn't understand women, guys.
He's like, women are so unpredictable.
How did we even start arguing?
I just asked how your day was and apparently I didn't notice
that she was tired I'm sorry
The fuck I just asked how your day was I'm sorry Oh my god,
it's like me for real
Like why are we arguing what happened?
Yeah, what did she fuck me for?
Do you be like that sometimes?
I don't like how quiet it is.
Can I go inside?
There was like a door.
I don't know if there was a door inside.
No.
Is there anything here, though?
Any hidden items?
This place is a mess.
Let's look around.
We should search for more information.
Miyato Musashi is never married for a reason.
But I should think it was super challenging.
Thank you.
There was a hell of a fight here.
These appear to be drag marks.
Oh shit, that's a boss fight.
It wasn't gentle.
That's a boss fight right there.
Look at this way.
But there's items this way though.
Oh shit, there's items everywhere.
I'll go here first.
He only needs his sword and his virtual waifu.
Oh fuck, I didn't realize she was gonna talk!
I was trying to spam the items!
Oh no, now she's gonna be mad at me.
Okay.
We're supposed to get around the pond.
This here.
I mean, we're around the... Yeah, we're around the pond now.
Yo yo
More claw marks They continue all the way to the other side
It appears our quarry is the new way The new way Again
they're composed of paths from other creatures But Yorimasa
destroyed it long ago Okay
All right The trail ends here Oh, there's a door there.
Let's just keep going.
Yeah, I was going to say, I can't just walk past the pond.
It's a fucking pond.
It's not that deep.
Oh, shit.
What's going on?
Stop the new one.
That's the new one?
Oh, no.
Do I have to dodge like...
She's dead.
We're not saving anybody here.
Oh, no.
No, I have to dodge lightning now.
I have so many things to worry about.
And lightning's going to be one of them.
Get back here.
Oh, no.
I have enough things to worry about, guys.
Okay.
I'm not sure from here.
Oh, my God.
What?
It's not registered.
That was a bomb.
The thing!
Oh.
I don't like that.
Oh no.
Oh, not the lightning.
Yeah, fuck that one pot in particular.
Oh, it's that mad now.
He's like, yeah, fuck who?
Huh?
Oh.
Fuck you.
Wait, which way is this way?
Oh, hey, box.
Okay, that's good.
We need that to enhance our sword.
This way.
She's still alive?
Ma'am, stop holding on.
It's too late.
Just go follow the leg.
Stop running and fight me.
Come on.
Come to the light, ma'am.
How do I get up here?
Oh, is there another ladder?
Is there...
We're up there ladder.
Oh, it's the ramp.
I see it now.
No, Dad already had his walkies.
He already had his walkies before stream.
There's no way he needs another walkie.
You just fuel for the gauntlets.
Whoops.
Oh.
Can you share?
All right.
Next one.
Oh, shit.
Okay, next one.
Oh, my God.
He doesn't want to give you.
He's like, stop camping.
He won't let me camp.
He's like, this is an honorable.
Oh, but he's allowed to stay in his quarry.
Oh.
Okay, now he's got...
Oh, these guys don't matter.
Back where you belong.
Oh, my God.
I see.
There's a hierarchy here.
He has favorites.
These guys are not as important.
The bow user spotted.
Smite him.
Yo, you have been...
inside bro that lady is still trying so hard oh shit she
lives please run you don't thank me later crazy
Oh my god.
That tail is formidable.
How about we cut it off?
Okay, when he does that, okay, I guess.
Aim for its tail.
Aim for its tail?
Okay.
Okay, that's not his tail!
The blocking is gonna hurt this much.
I'd better just evade its attacks.
Okay.
It's not gonna... Okay, that's good to know.
okay all right so okay so all he's just about all right
that's good to know
oh my god he's just patting me around
are you kidding me another bone made for a table oh my god I
want you, what do you want me to do?
Okay.
All right, that's fine.
That's fine.
Use the pillar's strength.
There we go.
Okay, I need a kill though.
All right, that's fine.
Or a block!
Oh my god, okay, no more blocks though.
I don't think I can.
For another block!
Boom!
Oh my god, I thought she was gonna do something else.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, I didn't predict that.
Oh, knowing him, he's going to have a phase two anyway.
Does it really matter?
Okay.
Oh,
my god.
Fuck.
Okay.
Yes!
Okay, phase one done.
Oh!
One phase!
There's no way.
There's no way I've never seen it.
One phase.
It's a mini boss.
Okay, alright, alright.
Oh.
Oh my god.
There's no second phase.
You mean life exists without phase two?
That's possible.
That's crazy.
i'm lost which way is which okay which way does this way go
okay we i'm gonna go this way i just realized there is a
mirror behind me i didn't activate it
okay let's grab the mirror i ran past the mirror and i
didn't know okay can i enhance i'll get the sword
okay I don't know he's just he's just very needy right now
He's very he's very bratty at the moment He wants food but I
don't have treats for him I don't have treats for him
Oh Getting into whoa What the fuck oh shit there's dead
people here I see ghosts I see dead people
Alright it's time to touch it Touch the black hole
I'll let you in, that's it.
Okay, he's just there to bark.
What?
What are they doing with the animals?
Now, this isn't live for a bunch.
They're just perfect for my next nuke.
Oh, they're making more chimeras.
That's what they're doing.
Oh, that there she is.
That's the missing troop member.
Oh my god.
Like she's gonna be a new way, isn't she?
She's gonna be a new way
Oh You shouldn't have ordered it.
So I've been patient with you, but There's a limit to all
things
clears with you she's only got one trick and it won't work
if her feet don't she can't dance no her cute he's a fool
i'm sorry oh she won't be able to dance again and all he can
do is watch oh
my girl just now Man's not helping.
It's like, like, in the nature documentaries.
They can't do anything about it, too.
I think, I remember, like, there was one instance where,
like, the penguins got snowed into, like, a little hole.
And then, like, like, the camera documentary crew actually,
like, broke their rule up, but not interfering because it
was just so sad.
And they actually built a ramp for the penguins to, um, to,
like, climb out of.
Yeah, they dug them out.
Like, this is, like, one instance where, like, they actually
broke the rule about never interfering with nature.
And we gotta save them because they're so lucky.
Those penguins are so lucky.
They have cute privilege.
They're pretty privileged.
Is this right?
I believe that is the purpose of this contraption.
elevator invented an elevator in the old feudal japan
all right where am i gonna get my mecca horse i'm ready oh
this is the this is the boss this is the boss room isn't it
there'd be a riot of word of this got out the officials and
soldiers would lose their minds i'm a killer friend aren't i
and bringing her home oh that yep This is a boss room, isn't
it?
Wow!
What am I going to do with all that open space?
It's a lot of open space, guys.
I know there's something here.
Looks so friendly and inviting.
Yeah, I know.
Okay.
Hello?
Hello, hello, mooshy mooshy.
Food re-delivery.
I have your food here.
We're gonna leave a five-star rating and a tip.
I might have been like an hour late with your food.
I really appreciate five-star.
Oh, hello.
Could be a mob gauntlet and then a boss.
It could be worse, you're right.
You know, Super Chat, thank you.
Taco, thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Help me, Doogie.
What was that?
This is creeping me out.
What does that mean?
I don't want to say it out loud because I don't know that
word.
I'm always paranoid.
If I don't know a word, I'm like, oh, I don't know if I can
say that out loud.
Alright.
What's that?
Is he okay?
Surely he's fine.
fine right hello hey sir how are you oh he has like spider
shit in front of him i see it he's annoying oh my god oh he
has the face huggers on him oh there's the face huggers
maybe i should kill him what the hell is going on there
Okay, I should be able to stop this.
Like, I know he's gonna get back up and fucking try to kill
me later.
An empty room.
Oh, not an empty room.
What's this?
Puzzle room.
Do not interfere, Doki.
Do not interfere with nature.
Okay, I should might have to stop.
We've been barking so much.
All right, give me a sec.
I'm actually worried.
He's barking too much.
Hey.
Why?
Why not?
All right.
Let nature take its course.
It's only the circle of men.
What's all this noise?
Something is wrong here.
What could be waiting for you?
I don't like this.
all right so there is something over here
all right so i go in the elevator i go through this door um
all right oh it's going the elevator i think they all have
like the magic the ticks on them we can't interfere with
nature guys we're gonna cause a butterfly effect there's a
crazy i know and i wasn't invited so fucked up they invite
me to the party
look just because I got a wife now doesn't mean I can't
still party guys
like I still got it come back later oh she's like the
scientist oh what the fuck holy shit
that's so careful You've died for the same since you got him
married.
Oh.
Oh, I don't like that.
Like a smitten little duckling.
I don't like that.
Your sister is my enemy.
Nothing less.
And nothing more.
Nobody's thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Boss fight time.
And after everything you and your awful kind put him
through.
He had the potential to become a hero who could lead this
land to peace.
She's so creepy.
That's why I chose you.
You saying that with a straight face enrages me.
No matter how you look at it, it should be me who...
Hey.
Hmm?
Oh, where are my nanos?
Hello there, fallen samurai.
were you feeling left oh my god her movement too makes me so
uncomfortable uh
wait wrong thread whatever was i thinking with this one such
a mess oh this time
oh what the fuck oh so what do you think it's my latest work
i'm quite pleased with it my Oh!
Oh!
What the fuck?
I wonder what her weak point is.
I wonder where the weak point is.
He has a very, very rich.
Yeah, red eyes.
That I have matters to attend.
you the mind to follow take your time i wonder what this bow
is for don't worry they'll never figure out his weak spot
just wait oh of course i set the thing up to dispose of
rubbish or it soon so sorry about that oh i get a little i'm
not here to play get a little slide done it has pink okay
careful careful don't touch the eye has pink eye he looks
really happy about oh my god oh my god
there we go nothing that master is playing with us we're not
leaving here so she's dead it is stabble but first we need
that key we have no choice but to go after it all right go
this way oh never mind i guess we don't go that way where's
the trap door It was like right here.
Okay, it's a lot smaller.
Oh, wait.
I mean, are they dead now?
I thought they were what happened to them.
They're not they're they stopped screaming They're still
alive, right?
They're like petrified now.
Oh, yeah, that guy that thing's dead for real They're just
sleeping.
It was a wild night, guys
It's a very wild night with her.
Oh, is that blood?
These monsters are getting so creepy now.
I do not, this area is creepy.
This area is very creepy.
We did really well with the character design for this one.
In the movement.
It was a very wild party.
all right
it is a lot of blood we don't have to worry about blood
transfusions for a while
okay why not have some fun with my creation oh oh which one
is this oh which one is this okay these are not as bad use
the pellet strength A pillar?
What pillar?
Oh!
Wait, there's nothing here?
Okay, I- Oh shit!
No!
I didn't realize my HP!
Okay, I thought there was like something for me to
fucking...
Alright, my wife aided me, guys.
My wife aided me, I thought...
I thought there was a...
Oh, my sumo!
When she said pillar, I keep thinking like...
I was thinking like, um...
There's a pillar for me to pick up.
There you go.
So ropes are meant to be cut.
Alright.
Okay.
I'll understand my wife someday.
A door with a face.
Yeah, what do I do with that?
It's a puzzle.
Well, I must have to, like, find something to put in the
face.
Like, all Onimusha games.
Oh, my God, we're inside.
It's so harder to use my gun inside.
I like the environment design, too.
Where does this go?
Okay, not here.
Aww.
Cool.
Anything above?
Oh, oh, there's animals here.
Oh, that's cute.
Look at all these animals.
They're all friends.
Are these the animals from that cart?
Where is them?
I presume they'll the raw materials for the new way it seems
they are they're all friends there it's like a little mini
zoo okay there's huh i wonder if wonder there's monsters up
there which one do i want to all right i'll get him ah don't
bitch oh my god oh my god i was so i was so ready to you
fucker your actual fucker all right my turn
my oh my turn glamour oh what the fuck
okay there you go No challenge.
Right in the eye.
Alright.
I got the high ground now.
It's a good thing that Beaumont shot me.
It's my turn to cheese it.
Oh, I wish it was like deadlock like you slide and get all
these fucking jars out of the way.
Or having to cut it one by one.
I thank you so much for the ring.
Oh, we had a good stream.
Is this head take damage?
It does not.
Damn.
That's good to know.
I actually have to cut him.
Oh, my God.
He's like a little roly-poly.
There you go.
Well done.
Oh.
Alright, we got a power stone.
What's above me?
I assume it has to be, like...
What?
Uh-huh.
Is there something above me that I didn't get?
Oh, it's the fucking berries.
Okay, never mind.
I didn't even need...
Okay, actually, I do need it.
Create more health.
I feel like eventually I'm gonna run out.
Because I haven't been picking them up.
Oops.
I should be picking them up everywhere I go.
All right, let's see.
Nice, I gotta break everything.
I'm gonna break this too, just in case.
He doesn't see that.
Wait, that didn't hit him?
It's literally right there!
Oh, he's like, Food!
Like, I'm so hungry.
Yeah.
Shit.
He's fine, he's not worrying.
Whoa, what the fuck?
How you- Okay, smartest man out there.
Alright.
That works.
If it works, it works.
That's it.
There were no much for you at all.
Is this a... Do I can push?
Okay, no.
So I want to be sure.
All right.
Oh, I almost did what he did.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Can he actually chop him?
Okay.
All right.
I'm so lucky.
Oh my god.
That's
it.
That's it.
Oh my god!
What?
Okay, there you go.
Oh, he's so bratty today.
He's not hungry.
He ate everything.
No.
Why?
Okay, you walked away.
Alright, there is one key to it.
I put him in my bed, but then I can't supervise him, and I'm
worried he will jump off the bed.
Because I need him to stop doing that I need to stop I need
him to stop What oh my god because his sword was against his
head it blocked it.
Oh, that's so smart That was like so unintentional that was
one-sided Let's keep moving They should why aren't they
carrying a bow and a they should be carrying a bow and a
sword.
That's not enough stupid or some shit.
Yeah, grab more of these.
Alright, nice.
Alright, off we go.
Okay, cut.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm ready to enhance my pouches.
Let's go.
Oh, fuck.
He has a helmet.
Oh, fuck, they had two health.
Wait.
Ew.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, should I guess I should suck this before?
Yeah, yeah.
I am.
Would you even try?
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
Yeah.
There you go.
That's right!
Get beat up!
Oh, get combos!
Boom!
Oh, shit.
I got combos.
Oh, shit!
That's it.
It's not wise to use it on these guys, but whatever.
Whoops.
Don't have that for a boss fight.
That's okay.
Future Doki will worry about that.
Because Shavu, this is a boss fight.
Right here.
thank god we're not there yet we're not oh it's we are
almost there
oh no oh no what unpleasant masks what could they be for
what could they be for that weird gemma put them here it
can't be anything good okay which seems like the less scary
this was
something bad happens?
Did you like hit...
Oh!
What?
Wait, what?
The hanging masks.
They remind me of archery targets.
What's the hint?
Oh.
What's the sound?
Oh, wait, it's that.
Oh, it's one of the faces.
Oh
Oh Maybe each face mean Oh, well I shot that one first Is it
All right, let's just randomly shoot one
Dev what didn't do Okay, I didn't do anything.
What could we be missing?
Hmm.
Masashi, does anything in the area catch your eye?
Do I feel like...
I am curious about the illuminated masks.
Adult Doko arranged things like this on the whim.
I feel like...
Am I supposed to meet this face?
It's a mouth and eyes.
It's not really that much.
I think it's just these two, honestly.
That is?
Okay.
I'm missing something.
What am I missing?
The light passing through the masks.
Yes, I know!
It seems to be shining out beyond this room.
Oh my god.
How did I get it?
One, two, three, four.
We learned the count.
That did it, Missashi.
All right.
A strange master, Mir, so it was just...
Oh, my God.
Let's learn our ABCs!
There we go.
Oh, my God, guys.
She did it.
Doki learned to count the four.
Where am I supposed to go?
Back here?
There is a chest here.
How the fuck do I grab this chest?
There's a chest here.
Whatever.
Figure that out.
Future Doki will figure it out.
Okay.
Enhance.
What can I enhance?
This doesn't matter to me, honestly.
Oh.
I need a power stone for that later.
We unlocked the door.
Door unlocked.
Oh, there is.
Yeah, okay.
Oh my god.
Door unlocked to a new door.
Oh, god damn it.
Don't have...
Oh, man.
This looks like an arena.
Something seems different, Sashi.
Let us investigate.
It's Warrior Omnis!
I'm grabbing this treasure, I don't care.
Well, okay, something's gonna come out of that fucking room
and then I get treasure at least.
Can you use?
Okay.
Oh.
I'm gonna shoot something here.
I'm gonna do it.
Is there?
Something I was supposed to shoot?
Huh.
I'll check this door.
What does it lead to?
Oh.
I just didn't get close enough to the door.
What?
Rune your arms.
Oh, that's a giant.
I didn't tumor him.
Okay, not gonna lie.
What?
I started with X!
That's bullshit.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit.
That's so bullshit.
That's so bullshit!
Oh my god, he's sucking my souls.
What is he doing?
Oh my god, that's bullshit.
Oh my god!
What is he doing to me?
We're in danger here.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's how I'm killing you.
I'm killing you.
I don't care.
Alright.
Now I can get
you all right nice fine silver all
right that should be it right well it
seems that got the door open okay open sesame all
right at least like I still have enough I still build up
shit for my oh look at all these animals they're all so good
friends hanging out look at that it's like Noah's eyes how
we can create the hybrids you know fall in love and we're
gonna have new animal species and that predator the suitopia
why are we stopping is she messing with us again
what happened to me what
What's happened to me?
Oh shit, these are all like the the new ones
They have What's happened to me?
Edward
It's a small world after all come on It's a small world
after all After all, it's a small world.
After all, it's a small, small world.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's what it is.
Can't wait for Disney to have that as a ride.
I told you, I can tell.
I can tell that we're gonna find the girl, and then she's
gonna be like, Sophie.
I feel it.
It's the right way.
There's some lore here.
Alright, let's see.
Chest.
How fortuitous is this?
Sophie.
Where's the mirror, though?
We need a mirror.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, no, is this the...
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Because there's more rooms behind me, too.
Alright, we're definitely dead here.
We know I love you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Oh, and I'm going in with no heals, guys.
We have fallen into a trap.
Oh, yeah?
You think so?
Just keep coming.
There we go.
We got that out of the way.
You're nothing.
Okay, no, it's going to me first.
Ah, shit, not the fucking helmet.
Two
minutes.
I sent it.
Alright.
That's five.
The pellet strength gets stuck at them.
Boom!
Okay.
We got one other way.
Oh, shit!
Oh, come on.
Alright, I got that, though.
Alright, so we do have Big Boy.
Big Boy here, luckily, does not know what's going on.
And I'll take that.
Big Boy is a little confused.
And that is okay.
Another really dangerous battle.
Be careful.
Okay, I don't think I should have done that.
Maybe that was a bit.
I think me...
I think he was optional guys.
I think he might've been...
I could've..
I think he was optional guys.
I think...
I think I think he was an optional fight.
No!
No, not again!
I just have to keep parrying until I get there.
Oh, no, not him!
Not him!
Now fall!
This thing's gone completely bad!
Oh, no!
Not again!
I don't know what to do!
Okay, wait.
It's not who you've got.
No!
Oh my god!
Holy!
That was a crap!
It's raining, it's not good for me!
All right.
All right guys.
Hey!
No!
No.
Guys, that might have been a mistake.
You just fueled.
Oh, no, not again.
Not again.
Okay, there you go.
I'll take that.
Oh, whoops.
There you go.
Okay, now that I know.
Just try and stop me.
There you go.
Boom!
Okay.
Whoa!
Okay, I can use this, though.
And then...
Boom!
Oh, fuck!
Maybe that works!
That works!
But it looked cool, though.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm not dying again.
Oh, that's fine.
Guys, I'm not dying.
I'm not dying.
I'm not dying today.
They never make it easy.
All right, do we do it?
Okay, how much do I, how much loot do I get for killing him?
How, guys, how much loot would I get?
Is it worth it?
There's so much loot.
Climb by me, you're on.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Wait, I still only have two?
Okay.
Oh my god.
What force and power?
Um, I don't know.
I...
Guys, I don't know about this anymore.
I don't know about this anymore.
Let's listen, you work, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
If I do this, then I go.
Boom!
There you go.
You got one?
Alright, there you go.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, this is bad.
This is already bad.
It's fine.
Got one.
Rise yourself.
Oh my god, please.
All right.
Are you kidding me?
He was 1 HP.
guys i don't know guys i don't know if i'm strong enough
okay all right there's what we do we have a lot of items
okay uh
oh shit what the fuck I have souls for days.
Okay.
We'll eat this for a while.
We're gonna eat this.
We're gonna wait.
And then...
Okay.
Say we have so much time.
We have so much time, guys.
I don't want to put this sort this into my shit okay we're
gonna swap this wait we're gonna send this
oh my god okay we're gonna send this the storage and then
wait how do I put oh my god I can't do it alright don't
worry it's fine it's totally fine okay and then I'm charging
it up he doesn't know fine by me I do that and then got one
and then and then boom okay
Oh my god.
Gather blazing energy into a fight.
Then you'll be able to press the attack.
Oh!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Are you serious?
I'm pressed!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Be careful.
I pressed B!
I pressed... Oh, I did!
I did press B!
You're so right!
You're so right, Gabe!
You're so right.
I knew I pressed it too.
At least the game knew that too.
Thank God.
Oh my God.
Nice.
It's ripping its axe in my eyes.
I need one.
I need to run from that.
Are you serious?
All right, there you go.
Nice!
What are that struggling got you nowhere?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, that was close.
That was fucking close.
Okay, I got items from that, though.
Thank God.
All right, hell is...
We're free.
We're fucking free.
All right, we got it.
Okay, I got the timing for that down.
For the fucking grabs.
All right, now we can leave.
All right, prank that soldier boy.
And now we have all the healers possible.
Oh.
Easy, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
All right, thank God he doesn't wear a helmet.
There we go.
One less thing to worry about.
All right, this is where I got the rich.
Yeah.
Oh, I couldn't even open that if I wanted to.
Oh.
All right, where is he?
Where is he?
There you go.
Can we open your eyes?
Oh, okay.
Oh, they multiply now.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, that's bad.
Okay.
Got the deflect on that though.
Well done.
All right.
Oh!
Oh, hey, thank god he missed.
Boom!
Got your other eye.
Nice.
Who the hell wears a metal hat?
Exactly.
Freaks?
Too heavy for your head.
It's inconvenient.
What if you accidentally cut your neck, huh?
all right all right
okay try to get over here get over here where's the door oh
they locked the door oh shit don't don't don't use the
pellet strike all right thank you wife oh it's a pretty
Appreciate that advice Yeah, you like that?
Yeah, you like that?
Yeah, that's fucking right
Whoa Oh shit, he boomed me back Oh shit, I can't see Compose
yourself Oh
Okay, this guy, this guy is scary.
Okay, here we go.
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
He's one.
He's actually one.
Holy shit, that guy's tanky.
Oh, my God, there was a fucking thingy here, too.
I could have used that.
Sure, he's not good at it.
I'm using an arrow.
Small friend.
Oh, he's not small friend.
No!
I can use this.
I have to use this.
Okay.
Oh, sure, there's not another boss fight here for me.
There you go.
These guys are just so tanky.
They're real.
As long as they don't multiply.
Should be good.
Oh, thank God they don't multiply.
Oh, is there anything here?
It's another face door.
Oh, never mind.
Oh.
Wait, what?
What's over here?
Shit, which way do I...
May I go here, grab the thing, and then go to the mirror?
Where do I go?
Wait, which store do I go, guys?
You go left or...
Should I grab the mirror?
I can't tell.
I guess this is a shortcut.
It must be the shortcut.
Yeah, you're right.
Let's go this way.
It's not feel safer.
I already grabbed it because the mirror's not highlighted.
Because the mirror itself isn't highlighted, so I assume I
already grabbed it.
Oh.
He's hallucinating me now.
Aw.
The best show the world's ever seen.
As long as you're happy, then I'm...
It's trying to cope.
No.
Yeah, she's broken.
Don't take her away from me.
No!
Oh.
I
want to keep dancing.
With Okuni forever.
Okuni.
Dance.
Dance with me.
No.
Come on.
No, your head!
No!
Don't give your head so tired!
Oh, she's having a psychotic breakdown.
We'll find her.
We'll save her.
And we'll get her back to where she belongs.
Oh, she is 100%.
Oh, I don't know.
We can un- un-hemoculite her.
I don't know.
It doesn't look like we'll be able to un-Kamaya her.
Oh, this does not look good.
Uh, she...
Maybe she's like half-tagged.
Wait, maybe?
Cat girl?
Maybe?
Potentially.
I mean, why tigers?
You know?
Guys, guys!
Guys, there were tigers there next to her.
Cat girl?
Possibly?
Maybe?
It could work!
Ah, there it is.
That's the arena we all love to see.
There we go.
I'm sure nothing bad happens in this room.
It's not, it's like tomato juice.
Oh, what?
Oh, I don't have time for these students.
games what am i supposed to do about this use your eyes
god damn it i won't be killed by some maniac stupid toy
let's touch you aim for the moving part i tried oh my god oh
my god where am i missing oh my god right here
Ah!
Oh, Don't Don't He just bury it!
Not even close!
What?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Oh, no, go, go, go, go.
Not even close!
Don't He bury the place!
I did!
Don't get raised right there!
I'm getting really sick of this.
Are we done yet?
See?
I told you I buried it.
I am sick of this crazy game.
When my wife told me to use my eyes.
Oh, Toki, listen to your wife, but not us.
When we told you to use your eyes.
Look, it's different.
That's my wife.
Made by only that completes energy charge to increase their
power.
Enemies in a given area and really we can breakable armor
use RAB to charge increase the damage they dealt.
I feel like Health is always I don't know.
I feel like I'll always just go with health.
There's no like the thing is the thing I hate is that you
can't abuse the mechanic where
Wait, do you do massive stamina damage?
Is it really that good?
I mean I'll try I just don't like that.
That I can't use multiple weapons.
Like, you know.
I wish it was like.
And it doesn't take away my bar from the other weapons.
That's what I hate.
That's what I don't like about this new game.
It's just that I like the one I can, like, combo it, you
know?
I like the combo system.
In the older Onimusha games.
Yeah, they all share one resource.
I can't cheese it.
We know I love cheesing.
Okay, I'll charge this up.
I'll save.
I mean, I have auto save, but I'll save just for fun.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Oh.
that's awkward I go back down there though it's fine I can
go back and see what I miss oh there it is that's what we
were talking about earlier what is it now you
come for the finale oh no
oh is she one of them is she one of them I'll by the end of
this.
Oh no, now I have to deal with.
I'll send you both back to hell.
Oh my god.
Run to yourself.
I can't even use it!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, I can't see which one is it.
Which one?
Which one is the one that's...
It's blue.
Okay, what do you got?
Let's focus on blue.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Oh my god, this is so rough.
This is so rough right now.
That's not blue!
This is blue.
Oh god.
Okay, they come.
Okay.
Blue!
Stop blocking me!
I'm trying to grab the blue!
Okay.
We gotta get the blue first.
Oh my god.
There you go.
Are you kidding me?
Okay, there you go.
all right blue gun blue gun all right there you go red tap
all right there you
okay wait wait oh shit run white all right we got the
stamina broken at least all
lock damage break oh shit I can't where am I
that was so hard he got me he couldn't attract me
don't give them an opening I swear to God wife I'm trying
not to okay All right.
There you go.
It's like, she's saying as if I wanted to give him an
opening.
It's like, there you go.
Oh my god, that was close.
Two.
There you go.
Nice!
And you!
Five!
There we go.
I love my backseeding wife.
She backsees me so well.
Yeah.
He's just up ahead.
Ah, one thing.
My Gimma are very busy telling the key sentry they're apart.
Dear dear and leave them to it.
Wait, what?
No.
Don't worry, there's still another Onimusha.
The other Onimusha is protecting him, right?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, door tie.
What do you mean?
There's no way.
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
I'm pretty sure they're doing...
The sanctuary's okay.
Yes.
There's other samurai's in the world.
It's not just me.
I was so worried that the...
Senua would recharge his stamina, but thank God he didn't.
I don't know how I would be able to get that done.
them locate the source of the commotion this is where at
least what yeah all right where are we oh this must be where
she is imperial palace oh fuck oh we might be a little too
late what did i want to increase the amount what do i want
to get for that.
Oh, for a long draw.
Okay, we should get that, actually.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
The emperor!
Oh, it was the imperial palace.
The emperor's gonna be fine, right?
We'll attack it from below.
We have enough on our plate, looking for Okuni's friend.
Now we gotta protect the imperial.
Okay, there's nothing to protect anymore, to be fair.
Uh...
I have to be fair, there is nothing left to protect.
Whoa!
But where did he come from?
That's it.
There were no much for you at all.
Everybody should be fine, right?
He's having me all right, guys.
I have really made a mess of the place.
Dogger is surely up ahead.
Teleports behind me.
We must get this area under control.
That's a headshot.
Oh, I thought I'd let...
Oh.
It's all right.
Cool.
There you go.
Yeah, easy.
Oh.
There we go.
Easy.
But what's over here?
Is it just not crawlable?
Oh, am I supposed to?
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Oh, this treasure.
Okay.
Oh, it looks like a fucking fighting area.
Unless... Oh!
Ah, fuck it!
I knew it!
I'm just gonna chop the rest.
Wasting my time.
What the fuck?
What a waste of my...
You guys are a waste of my time.
That was fun.
Alright.
I think I should just chop these guys.
I think the flying one, I can just chop.
Honestly.
They're not really that much of a threat.
They don't have, like, armor that they worry about.
It's literally just a swordsman that I should...
that bow and then the flying ones i chop chop chop
and more berries grab the berries for heels how much berries
do i have anyway my storage right we have 60.
that's good oh he's a better bow man worth it
Oh, there's a mirror here.
Wait, did I just...
Okay, no.
Alright, I'm ready for another boss fight.
It's like a boss rush.
From one boss fight to the next.
It's coming.
Is it her?
Is it the dancer?
Is that her?
And she has her feet now.
That has to be her.
Yeah, that has to be her.
Look, you can dance!
Look at that!
You're so, you're beautiful now!
Only is the perfect appetizer for a palace, don't you think?
It's gotta be her.
It's a striking debut for my beautiful, great Anuhi.
Oh, oh, there.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, those look like...
Yeah, because she was, like, talking to the top.
All the odds on the menu.
It's an improvement.
Now you have four legs instead of two.
An affordable attack?
God, are you kidding me?
So many lives destroyed.
Just to create this one beast.
Ah!
Okay.
You can stand?
Me too.
Okay, this is a lot harder now.
Now that I know he can stand.
Don't give them an opening.
You have the way you want them in the sessions.
Oh my god.
Okay,
this is a little bad for me But There we go As if you
weren't disgusting enough Alright, there we go Stop making a
fuss That's right Oh shit Wait, how many news How many
people's sacrifices does he have?
Oh my god, fucking curse
I can't see I actually can't see right now
Oh my god Oh, he's sucking it up No, that was a threat
Oh, that's just bad for me That's so bad Be on your guard
What do you mean is a bug You're a fucking lightning Do your
worst There you are oh my god so
much harder to predict where she's standing don't give them
an opening what am i trying you should be able to carry it
you must heal quickly
i'm dead i'm dead don't give them an
opening you can't
Oh my god, there's a second face.
There's a second!
You're documenting your power for the last one.
No fucking coins!
There's a
second!
Okay, do your worst.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, I fucked up.
Don't give them an opening.
Why?
I don't know if you know this.
But I swear to God, I'm not.
What if I swear to God?
I am not.
Okay.
Oh my God!
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Right there.
Aw!
Off you come!
Full-time war.
We should have to find some hose again.
Alright.
Here we go.
Here we!
Here we go!
Stop making a fuss!
Just go down.
And stay down!
There's a tail!
Go.
You dropped something.
What?
Damn it.
Okay.
This dance again.
There.
All right.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
Damn it.
I missed the last one.
I was so close.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to cut this thing down and feed it to the group.
If someone has to wield its energy, it's better than it's
me.
Oh, my God.
I'm off my groove.
I'm off my groove now.
Just give them an opening.
okay all right you can stand okay there you go all right i'm
gonna try i'm gonna try i'm gonna focus up right now
okay what happened okay so you're like do your worst All
right, there we go.
No, no, I got too cocky.
All right, okay.
Okay, oh my God, I was almost first tried it too.
I almost first try, I'm getting, okay, I need to like not
get too cocky now.
Cut this thing down and feed it to the core of it.
There's someone has to wield its energy.
Oh my God, now he's doing moves.
I, there you go.
It's like doing moves that wasn't there before!
Do your worst!
There we go.
You can stand?
Okay.
There we go.
Right there.
Oh!
Off you come!
What now?
Get a taste.
Okay, it's bullshit that...
so mad I'm so mad I'm actually so mad I'm actually so mad
there you go as if you weren't disgusting enough this is
beautiful here you go
beast i know i was like you can miss what do you mean you
can miss you don't get to just grow that back okay there you
go stop making a fuss just go down stay down yeah Yeah!
All right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here we
go.
There we
Those people are locked up on the ground.
And while that lunatic with the shoes was doing, that was
all just to create monsters.
Oh.
This is a game.
Can you?
Their actions fall beyond the realm of comprehension.
These monsters are phase two, phase two.
It's about to use lightning.
Be on your guard.
I'm so mad.
So mad.
Light me oh no with a power on me only you should be able to
have it
Actually no actually fuck you Stop making a fuss just go
down Fuck you I hate you.
I hate you so much How'd you feel of lightning?
I don't remember it.
There you go.
I know how!
Who's talking about it?
Okay.
Oh, I can't dodge anymore though.
Don't give them an army.
Alright, there you go.
There you go.
Do your worst.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Stop making a fuss.
Just go down and stay down.
All right.
Another one.
I need to heal a little bit.
You seriously combo me there?
Fuck you!
No, I'm glad you can't dance anymore!
You deserve it!
I'm bold!
Shit!
Oh!
Okay, my god.
Okay, okay.
I was like, I didn't know if I should get greedy.
I was like, I did it.
I did.
I fucking did it.
Third time is a charm.
Guys, it's clicking.
It's clicking.
Everything's clicking.
I figured that out.
I figured out how to play this.
game it's no longer this is baby it's no longer hard for me
this is the easiest game i've ever played easiest soul play
another today i was only going to watch but not if you're
here you freak oh it's you you're the little one from the
dance troupe augury get back where's hanaki where indeed i
did bring her here but that was just an errand i ran for
your Oh.
You need to get out of there.
There's no need for the answer.
You're right.
How does she miss?
He has a four feet neck.
Oh, it's him.
I prefer to keep the wise and strong around for later use.
Your friends seem to fit the bill well enough, but...
lost interest oh inagiku your friends are here come on out
that wasn't her oh wait that's her
closure does he even get to be a tiger oh come on
Oh, I thought I'd try my hand at Tokyo's hobby, but it seems
I made a mess of things.
I suppose one must walk before they can dance.
Oh, never mind.
We can fix her, right?
We can uncommire her.
Wait, we can fix it?
But she can dance though.
Oh, okay, well, like, sort of.
I mean, she can walk.
She can walk.
Is this something?
Please.
I can marry her right now.
Just like how Edward fixed you.
With me.
Yoshitsune.
Don't go.
Oh, that's...
No atrocity of that mankind could surprise you.
Oh, I'm sorry.
What is she gonna do?
All she can do is just grab me.
Like...
I'm scared I feel sick.
Oh, I can't even headshot her.
It hurts.
Oh, she's gonna...
All she can do is just grab.
Yo, we'll just cut off the gross parts out.
Be fine.
Alright, well...
I have to chop you.
I'm sorry.
Don't kill me.
Wait, she doesn't...
Oh, she grew her arm back.
It's fine.
It'll be fine.
Don't worry.
Just think about all the fun dance times.
Hey.
Don't...
She's okay, see?
She's fine.
Don't put with me.
You just look, focus on the face and everything will be
okay.
I won't do them, Yuri.
I won't let anything stop you, darling.
We'll dance.
Just the two of us.
Aw.
Life is so cruel.
All it had to give me was one gauntlet.
Ockney, I'm...
I don't think the gauntlet would have done anything.
It would make it so she would have to kill her.
Like...
If anything...
I can suck the soul.
Yes!
Come into my sword, my gauntlet!
Suck it!
I hope people still remember our Kabuki dolls from my
gauntlet.
Way into the future To be like both of us living forever
Feed the godlet I won't let them forget Inagiku About you,
or us Or Adolf No, my food, my souls My upgrades Could you
carry her?
Oh, nice!
Yay!
Yum yummy!
I think she needs to the wrath look she consented that's
gonna go so well in my sword upgrade
what powers did she give oh my god my legs
oh i like how the powers are like sumo related too i'm going
to borrow strength for a little while nice now i have a leg
and arm game
you better use it to send your shitsune and dokyo to hell
now i can dance for her
see you guys now she can live on as my new feet upgrades can
you hear me oh
Yeah, I knew it.
Why are you a butterfly?
Can't you talk to me like a normal person?
Not if you're outside.
I hate the outside.
Oh, she's a neat.
If I have need of you when you're outside, I will be using
this butterfly.
More importantly, details.
I want to hear them, so come here at once.
Pain in the ass.
Hmm.
It's an even sadder story than I expected.
I feel just terrible for the victims.
I'm not letting this be the end of it.
I'll give the bastards behind her what's coming to them.
Hmm.
Musashi, if nothing else, you appear to be a good person.
In that case, I have a job.
job for you with pay naturally yeah i like the way you talk
lady you're speaking my language my lion dogs haven't been
returning home usually they travel throughout kyoto
collecting heart wrenching tales for me such that i can stay
indoors then you request this that we help any lion nice
finally i'm being paid for something now one more thing
Kyoto is a place with no shortage of strange happenings.
But among them, there are some true mysteries, the kind that
set my heart ablaze.
You are to investigate them.
I will be there too, of course.
Or rather, my butterfly will be.
I said we weren't looking for a job.
Wait, wait, wait, we have no income.
We have no income.
Bro, bro, we need this.
And with that, I have writing to return to.
Unfortunately, I will have to ignore anything you say until
I conclude.
Like, you have no choice.
Take my money or die.
Look, we all hate, hate working, guys.
We need money.
Lion dogs are marked on the map.
Actually, I love my job.
I love streaming for you guys.
Lion dogs are marked.
I just don't like doing behind the scenes work.
Behind the scenes work is what I don't like.
Streaming is the fun part.
Dogs are marked.
I see them report.
Okay, we got...
Oh, those were the dogs.
It's a Musashi's Strange experiences and more rescued
Lineups and more moral stories.
They even come in a more Rescue the Greater Ward.
No?
Might as well.
Oh, Shady Realizer was a Second Page.
Fuck.
It... Oh my god.
God, yeah, look after your... Yeah, fucking Take care of
your dogs better.
I have a little... I have like a little door for it.
Wait, there it was.
Gemma notes.
What do these look like?
Okay, wait.
I missed a tip there, so I want to make sure.
Is there anything I missed?
Or was it?
It was like...
I missed the tip with the dogs.
I just want to make sure.
Does not tell me here?
Because there was...
was a second page.
So I was like, second page?
Oh, I guess I'll never know what the second page is.
I know.
I'm like, you can get the dog yourself.
It's gone.
I'll never see it again.
Oh, I got another.
Let's see.
I got a new coat.
Okay, this one's nice.
Yeah.
I'm a new a new tax bracket now okay i do want to okay
what's it here does anyone remember where it was that is it
here does anyone know where it was where i accidentally went
up the elevator is this one well does anyone know what floor
it was was it level two
because there was a collectible or something And I missed
it.
Level 2?
Is it this one?
I'll check.
Grand Theater?
Alright, let's check it out.
Let's figure this out.
It's definitely not here.
Maybe it's this one.
I'm trying to find the elevator.
Alright, there it is.
Something was glowing here.
Oh, there it is.
various case updated oh it was just fucking lord god damn
it's always just it's just a lord i thought it would have
been important all right let's fucking get this person's dog
this is like right there dad dad no no no no no all right Oh
my god, there's like so many things I unlocked in here.
Like, what about this?
Oh my god, you can literally...
God, just because you can't go outside.
Alright, get over here.
Go back to your owner.
Oh, okay, all is forgiven.
Oh god, he's so cute.
Never mind, everything's fine.
He's cute.
Yeah, it's pretty privilege.
Oh my god.
Laura?
Wait, Laura's here.
Oh, no, it's not Laura.
But a nice find.
I didn't get the treasure?
I did.
I just got it here.
Oh, okay.
What's this?
Oh, wait.
It's the light of bed.
Let's grab all the dogs first.
Oh, wait, there was a... there's a mirror here?
Wait, that was a chest?
I thought it was lore.
I thought that was lore.
I didn't realize it was an actual chest.
I was just like, ah, lore.
All right, I'll leave.
Oh my god, there was a chest.
I left because I just thought it was only lore.
Okay, holy shit, the load time is so fast.
It was lore and chess?
Oh my god.
Best of both worlds.
No, it was just lore.
I need to...
There was a mirror I had unlocked somewhere.
It was like here, right?
We're gonna go...
We're gonna go here.
I saw an unlocked mirror.
Like, unlocked, locked mirror.
Yeah, there it is.
But they're all just, like, next to the mirrors.
Oh, my God.
I'm literally, like...
Her Uber.
She's gonna go outside.
She's a neat.
The Mirasaki lady.
Wait, was there a chest that I forgot?
I don't know.
Wait, which way?
This way?
Oh.
Oh, I can't use my arrows because they're right.
Wait, I still can.
Be on your guard.
I still...
Are you talking about them?
I think they better be on their guard.
There's the mirror.
I'll grab the loot real quick here.
Nine-year socket.
That's some good shit.
Okay, let's kill these guys.
for...
Oh, that guy's a fat little picky.
Getting ready to be bursted.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, never mind.
Okay, this will hit.
There we go.
What the fuck is he ducking for?
This is bullshit.
I should be able to legally break that.
That was a fucking dragon.
I didn't notice
Really?
Is that all you've got?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's right, grab me again, bitch!
Depella's strength to the stag of them.
That's right!
Yeah!
Grab me again!
Oh, you can't!
Because you're fucking dead.
Alright.
Grab this.
Grab some berries.
some loot and more loot should be all the loot right now we
go and that's right
get diffed where the fuck is the dog is he up there what
where could the dog B he's inside oh there's a door okay he
is up there oh are you okay we got a little dirty don't
worry I'll clean you up little one whoa get clean there you
oh he's like tiger color too all right go back to your
knee-owner.
Eh.
Who may or may not be a hoarder.
Who knows?
Oh, that's a lot of them.
Oh, I can't wait to get my fucking pair from this.
I can't wait.
Ooh, I can't wait for some juicy pairs.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Boom.
Alright, your turn.
Alright, we're done.
Alright, give me your pairs.
Open up.
Wait, what?
Oh, I hope it wasn't this guy that died.
Why is it... what?
There was nothing here.
Why would they just hit?
I guess I fucking...
Whoops.
Must have had some group meeting or some shit I thought I
was like saving someone I must have interrupted like some
club meeting They're just they're just trying to hang out
Oops They're literally just chilling Hang out with the
homies some random samurai start killing all my homies
You're just trying to touch grass, Stokey.
No loitering.
What are you punks trying to do here, huh?
This is a residential area.
Get out.
Hello.
Get clean.
It's time to go home.
You're an inside dog.
Come on.
Oh, he's so cute.
All right.
Nine sages of decay It's like the fucking kingdom hearts
Finding the 101 Dalmatian Wee brothers are stone based Oh my
god they have lore They have their own lore Oh my god
There's dogs in every map Oh this is not that important to
me I'm sorry
This is actually 101 Dalmatian shit.
Alright, this reward better be fucking good.
Oh shit, okay, that was close.
Oh my god, I can't wait for my pair.
Oh, I cannot wait.
Ooh, that's a pair.
It's gonna be so juicy.
Alright, give me that pair.
You're dead.
I don't...
The reward is saving the dogs, Doki.
That's enough reward.
Oh, nice.
I got a pair.
Call it.
I knew it was going to be a juicy pair.
All right, get over here.
The fifth Dalmatian.
Alright, go back to your owner.
Alright, which one's the...
Oh, there was a treasure here.
We actually want to grab this treasure.
Alright.
Can I go from here?
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, alright, let's grab this treasure.
Treasure time.
Normally, I don't care much about, like, side quest stuff,
but, like, all of these are good upgrades, though, for my...
The fact that the upgrades are actually pretty... You
actually get upgrade materials.
That's making me do them.
Because normally I don't care.
But it does matter now.
Alright, um... Okay, I can grab the mirror and then go down.
I'll go down here, grab the last two dogs.
I definitely got better at this game, for sure.
Alright, kid, I'm leaving.
Kid, you're not that important.
The dogs are more important than you.
Evelyn Prudel.
I finally figured it out.
I figured out the blocking system.
It, like, finally clicked in my head.
So, what I was doing...
Okay, what I was doing, I realized what I was doing wrong.
I only click block.
Because I want to do...
I only clicked this when they were about to strike.
And then I realized it was very forgiven.
Forg- Forgiven.
Ah!
Very forgiven.
Because I can just press A instead.
I can hold this and then press A.
And that's when it clicked in my head.
Because all I did, I would do this at the moment they were
about to hit.
That's when I was fucking it up the most.
And I realized, wait a minute.
here, and then press A.
I can just time the A instead.
I was like, holy shit, and then it clicked in my head.
That's what I realized.
And I was like, oh my god, that makes it so much easier.
Yeah.
I was like, holy shit, I should have been doing that
instead.
That's why in the part one, I was struggling so hard,
because I was just clicking this.
I was just trying to do this.
Timing it?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, you can click use the deflect.
The deflect as the parry.
So I was just trying to time this, and I realized, why the
fuck am I doing that when I could just deflect instead?
I can just time the deflect, and it does the same thing.
That's how I figured it out.
There's, like, a chest here, but I don't know how to get
that.
What?
I said found them.
I'm, like, where?
Where?
Oh there.
Whoa!
Oh, what the fuck?
Who is he?
I was like, found who?
I didn't know where the guy was.
I had done this chest before.
I guess not.
God, this chest.
I thought I was hero before, but I guess not.
I made free loot!
Alright.
Yeah, I guess he did found me.
Alright, get clean.
Get clean.
Ding.
Alright.
Now that I found my playstyle.
It's now not the hardest game I've ever played now.
Now that I know, it has now become Not the hardest game
Because the only time I have to use dodge on it Like I can
deflect I can even deflect Like movement moves Like moves
related to movement stuff So like all I literally have to do
Is use my dodge For grabs And I already tie I know how to
tie my dodges perfectly Well not perfectly but like There
Like I know how to tie my dodges And it's literally The only
way it fucks Like the only thing that fucks with me is just
careful kid hang around in the place I can't do the easy
moves but my daddy he's not that's not a child that's like a
20-year-old trying to be a kid this is an orphan situation
how long has he been seven mommy died a long time ago bro it
sounds like he's like 20 years old how so well in any case
That's a little person.
I know what you are.
What do you want, Murasaki?
Kiyomi Sudara temple, he said.
I smell danger coming from that way myself.
Damn near work myself to death purifying that place.
Can't anything just stay fixed.
He's just cursed, Dokey.
go back to the temple i got everything wait what's this oh
it's just oh that's just the mirror uh-huh yeah they go back
to the temple is it yeah
oh wait i can upgrade now
all right wait was it here okay there it is different temple
oh my god i don't care i don't care about this at least i'm
sorry i don't care about these dogs enough i don't care
about these dogs enough i was right of course an intense
anger hatred even wait unless maybe the maybe lady murasaki
this will surely create powerful malice oh yeah i could open
the red wall now yeah okay wait wait all right let's see
what she gives me okay I'll see what she gives me, and then
I'll see if I care enough.
All right, let's see what she gets me.
What kind of rewards I get.
When I've been playing for five, it does not feel like five
hours.
This game is so fun.
I highly recommend checking it out.
You've done very well helping my lion dogs.
They are.
They're really cute.
Oh, shit.
literally a dog lady she has a problem here a token of my
gratitude please accept it
what do i get oh my god it's just closed it's it's it's just
it's cosmetics if it's not it's fucking cosmic okay what
does she give me what do i get oh my god it's my Okay, okay,
never okay.
It is pretty sick.
Okay.
It is all right Not gonna lie It is pretty sick.
I went up another tax.
Okay, that all right.
It was it was sort it was worth it never mind That's pretty
cool.
That's that's a cool story.
That yeah that that's some drip right there.
Oh, yeah I'm gonna get water real quick and use the
bathroom.
I'll be right back
I'm back.
That keeps thinking of treats for him.
I literally, like, went to the bathroom.
He broke in.
And he was like, treat!
Alan, Medi, Vinsta, Solid, Fight, L, and Papa, Space.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
And he's like, treat!
Where treat?
Not, please.
I'm trying to pee.
I...
Like, where's my treat?
I don't know why today he's like extra needy and hungry for
some reason I was like I didn't feed him and like I fed him
the same thing every day he gets fed I guess cuz like I
don't give him lots of treats like oh like my dog sitter so
he's like one she's like he's like if I keep asking she'll
eventually give me treats this way yeah if I just keep
asking I'm pretty sure that's his train of thought if I keep
pestering her she'll give me and I was like I don't have
anything that's the thing that's the thing I don't have
anything though like you could keep asking I just don't have
anything right on target yeah
all right I'm dual wielding right now just in case like
maybe it will work if I had food on me but I don't that's a
thing I don't have food on me so it's not gonna work
yeah I just use sword against the flying ones because they
just stand there
hello yeah I just got promoted what do you want yeah what do
you want i'm looking for someone
I'd like you to leave I said leave quickly your I have a
sword you're talking to some guy that has a fucking sword
anyone and also covered in blood don't be ridiculous lots of
nonsense this is why I hate samurai whoa what the fuck is
wrong him rude i'm not sure what's going on we'll just have
to follow him and figure it out yeah he's like not he
doesn't even have like anything to defend himself with it's
over is there i have to walk all the way i'm going back and
teleporting fuck that i'm walking back and tp i'm not it's
faster
It's too much walking, guys.
This way is faster.
There's, like, no mirror.
Look, look at this.
It's like, like, whatever.
I'm just going to fucking TP.
Thank God the samurai's invented fast travel.
Alright.
Yeah, this way is faster.
Also, I'm pretty sure there's going to be monsters there in
the way too i might as well just do this because i already
have nikki
yeah look at that boop i'm here now the samurai art of
teleportation exactly uh all right let's open that door what
the What?
Just because I feel like it right now.
Oh.
There you go.
And then you.
Can't be bothered.
There you go.
And I know I can grab this too.
Which is very convenient.
I feel like the chest refreshes itself or something.
They must have.
Because I loot it everywhere.
And I just...
I did not see this before.
They definitely refresh itself.
I'm gonna do this and grab the chest.
Or like...
They definitely generate loot.
It's like there's some places I know I've went to before.
Oh my god, there's a puppy there.
I know I went to before.
And then there's like new stuff.
Hello, little guy.
Come on, get clean.
Oh, it's so...
He's like sheep colored.
Look at him.
Oh, my God.
You're so cute.
Yeah, I love these guys.
They're so cute.
They're actually adorable.
But what's over here?
Okay, I knew it had to be loot.
It's like, that's dead end.
so I knew this was a dead end because I'll be over there for
the treasure I'm gonna grab no can I not pinpoint this oh I
can't oh I can take him guys I actually don't know if I can
oh my god oh my god oh my okay okay it's fine oh There we go
I don't know that No No I just have to get parried
All right, that's okay.
No All right, it'll take more than that Oh fuck Okay, maybe
I shouldn't do try this like that me okay there you go oh my
god wife the whole wife I swear to God I've tried
there you go please heal please No!
I've got you now.
Okay, nice.
Okay, maybe it'll be worth it.
Maybe it will be worth it.
Kill, kill, kill, kill, kill, kill.
There you go.
All right.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
What do you call that?
I got it!
Alright, nice.
Alright, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Oh my god, didn't realize.
Alright, there you go.
Another blow made for Sam.
It's fine?
Yeah!
This win is mine.
Oh I unlocked it guys guys, I told you I unlocked it guys
guys I told you I didn't lock that I figured it out I
figured it out.
I figured it out.
I figured out how this all goes right You know the pattern
now
It all it's all clicking this is the easiest soul's like you
have ever played It's all coming together I'm starting to
believe My third eye has opened
And I can open this door I'll
go down here And then we'll go to the Murasaki place
Okay I know the meta Exactly I read the patch notes guys I I
read the patch those guys I had early access I'll have my
revenge oh he's gonna turn to a demon or some shit isn't he
he's getting a little too obsessed revenge for what yeah
what's going on
Oh my god, okay.
That's not what I want to do, but that's fine.
You're nothing.
At least I followed that up and then get rid of this guy.
Like this guy and then...
Thank you.
Is that it?
Nope.
There was more is in there.
I've had it for just more.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
How did I get there?
Where am I?
All right, I'll get to take that out.
And then...
Oh, bro, just a Beyblade.
Why aren't you Beyblade?
That's literally what you were making.
He's doing melee builds.
Bro's trying to do melee builds.
All right.
I'm...
Get over here.
All right.
Absorb.
Suck.
he's no meta-built slave he's meta he's meta crafting his
theory craft and let him let him cook well your entire
purpose is to baby and yet you punch me my brother was
murdered he came here to study said he wanted to be a priest
oh shit some samurai named Ganyu put a sword through his
neck Oh my god.
Killed him in an instant.
We were there.
Gun near.
I thought if I waited here, he might come back.
But I might have a chance to avenge my brother.
If it's revenge you want, I'll get it for you.
We were there.
There's a kid waiting back there.
He's your son, right?
Go get him before something else does.
Yeah, we have a complicated relationship with your guy's
killer.
It's a little bit complicated.
Goddess Canon of the Stone Lantern.
A defeated warrior once carved the Goddess Canon into a
stone lantern with his fingernails and swore revenge.
Stone Lantern where the man was found is the very same way.
It seems the malice combined both the lingering vow in the
lantern and the man's own desire for vengeance.
Also, I just realized, like, after part one, that these are
real people.
I don't know anything about, like, you know, Japan history.
So I was like, wait, these three people are, they're, like,
actual historical figures in Japan.
I was like, oh my god.
these guys are real your assaults speak for themselves miss
I'll be counting on you for further investigations and lion
dog rescues don't suppose I can refuse I wonder how accurate
this is did you know they slaying demons and talking to us
shall we return to rockado chin on your temple missashi yeah
let's talk to the other two and figure out how to put
Yoshitsune and Tokyo down for good no wonder we lost
Japanese history and Capcom trivia wait actually can I talk
to her for more dogs you're rescuing life dogs at an
impressive rate or that musashi was a transfer student
that's true my lion dogs have brought reports and i must
read them i
didn't realize the characters were actually like um based
off of real people until like last until like the flat uh
after i finished part one with this i can write for now keep
it coming isashi do we get more drip oh wait she has more
dogs in her room now I just noticed that.
After I, like, rescued more dogs.
Her room is...
Oh, my God.
It's going to be all dogs.
She didn't give me anything this time.
Whoops.
All dogs.
Can I upgrade this?
Um...
Okay, I don't care much about Easton attacks because I
can't...
I don't know.
It just doesn't work.
Wait, absorbing soul.
while attacking?
Wait, that's so strong.
Wait, how do I do it?
Oh, while attack.
Okay, it's while I'm attacking.
Okay.
It's actually very convenient, though.
I actually need that.
Two charms.
Are you even have more than two charms?
Oh, shit.
Wait, all of these are good.
Okay, do we get petrify or absorb while attacking?
Which is better, dragons?
Petrify or absorb soul?
while attacking.
Because I can't tell.
I only have two power stones, so I can only do one upgrade.
Instead of, like, absorb while attacking?
Look at that.
Oh yeah, we have to...
I realized I forgot to upgrade.
Well, I have to go back here anyway.
Oh, blessed man.
The root of all evil.
Ooh, that's a lot of pressure.
Let's talk back to the little boy and grab some stuff.
Now where's the little boy?
What?
Okay.
Okay, it's this way.
Alright, let's grab our stuff.
Oh, this is a new mission.
Perfect timing, Samurai.
What do you say to a duel?
Oh, I don't have to read it.
Okay.
Huh?
I'm blessed by the heavens.
Countless fights and not a single loss.
All right, time to kill a man.
He consented.
Ports of monsters let me pass unchallenged.
I even jumped off the stage at Kyumizudera Temple.
Not a scratchy.
Maybe he's like triplets and now he's no longer a triplet.
You're feeling brave, samurai.
Ooh.
I'll look like a bandit when your luck runs out in the end
of my sword.
find someone else wait no it is free money boring it's
infinite money glitch now how am i supposed to test my
invincibility oh he's gonna please don't tell me this is an
escort mission that man surrounded by some bizarre malice
how very peculiar why do you say that sooner all right well
i have to follow him now where did that idiot run off to all
right let me i sent him out the bottom the slope near our
house i just hurry after him all right apparently he's
blessed with something all right let me see what i wanted oh
yeah i want to see if i could have to okay i already
upgraded everything all right all right where is he oh my
god he's all the way back he just walked all the way back
there okay all right let me tp thank god the samurai's
invented fast travel Very convenient for me.
Okay, I do want to upgrade my pouch, though.
I can upgrade it now.
I can't?
Fucking lie to me!
Oh, it's because I...
Oh my god, some of them...
They share the same materials.
Oh, I just noticed that.
So the pouch shares the same materials as, like, the item
upgrades, too.
Yeah.
Because I was like, I know I have the materials to upgrade
this.
Alright, is there a new training stuff?
I'm not fighting the boss.
A reflex combo.
Let's get started.
Alright, here.
Dodge the film.
Then press extra while.
Okay, that should have done this thing.
All right, come on.
Okay, I'm just gonna fucking kill you.
Come on, use your fucking sword.
Bro, they're not using their sword!
How the fuck am I supposed to do the dodge?
There you go.
All right, now I kill you.
All right, get over here.
That's where all your friends are dead.
Just sublime, boy.
Yeah.
Alright, an avoidable attack.
Let's get started.
Why have I seen these guys do it before?
Let's see.
Where...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I don't know the timing for that one.
Holy shit.
shit
All right, there we go.
Yeah, I've never seen a timing for that before
Nice Yeah, I was gonna say you could do that the entire time
and you don't even try okay earth shaker Let's get started
Oh Holy shit, that's so strong.
I just feel like during boss fights, I don't have time to
actually charge it like that.
You know?
Yeah, that takes way too long to charge.
Yeah, it takes so long to charge.
I don't think I have that time when I'm against the boss.
To charge it that fast.
all right I can but just feels like it's like a take a while
you do it after deflect okay I think I can try yeah all
right oh okay he's outside all right where's the invincible
man where is he let's get that the berries grow back to
because I really need that.
I'm always healing.
Alright, I'm ready for my duel.
Wait, where is he?
Hello?
Okay, I'll take the berries first, I guess.
Oh, he's in the house.
Hello?
Is that him?
are you two all right what happened a man came here ranting
about being blessed oh demanding a duel i tried to cut him
down but he got me he made off with everything we own the
world anything at all we're ruined that's fucked back there
was something unusual about him he moved like an amateur but
i couldn't do you know where he went actual skill diff dps
diff right there if i wanted a rematch he'd be at nendputs
the temple if you're going after him be careful
missachi the traces of mice he left behind have drawn gamma
to the area oh Aw.
I should have cut him down when I had the chance.
Yeah, I should have killed him.
All right.
Only he sees me.
Be on your guard.
Yeah.
All right.
It was awkward for me, honestly.
All right, there you go.
All right, stop sucking.
I need to remember that I can do this while I...
All right.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Hey there.
Oh shit!
Oh!
That's fine.
Wait there, guys.
Oh wait, don't worry guys.
I saved your life.
Can I have a pair now?
Oh fine, I don't fucking need your pairs.
Alright, where is he now?
Where did he go?
God, he went all the way there?
Okay, how do I get there fast?
I'm just gonna run there.
I won't fast travel.
They're ruined, Doki.
Yeah, but like, I saved their lives.
So I should get at least one pair.
That's all I ask for.
Don't ask for much.
Just a single pair.
Okay, I'm going to get these guys first.
Wait, I can suck while doing this.
These big boys or little boys?
Okay, that's a little boy.
So, I mean, that works too.
You just fuel for the goldmins.
Alright, oh, they were both.
They were both big boys.
Alright, five?
Don't worry, we're five.
Easy.
Alright, suck.
Should be...
Wait, how do I get there?
It's from this way.
Oh, hey guys.
Oh, that's awkward.
I mean, that's fine.
Alright, get out of here.
He has his babies now!
He's not worth my time.
He's barely worth my time.
Indeed, let us continue.
Yeah, I'm him.
I'm literally him.
I told you.
He's me.
I had 2K.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like I heard the word merging.
Our wavelengths are emerging.
I've become Musashi.
I'm the reincarnation of Musashi.
I haven't blessed after all.
Cut me if you can.
Wait, they work for him?
Oh, you're gonna work for a fucking human?
That's sad.
Oh, that, that.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
All right.
There we go.
It's because it's annoying.
If he wants to fight, why is he running?
Exactly, that's what I'm saying.
Soon all will be revealed.
Oh my god, just tell me now!
Oh my god, it's all the way up here.
Soon all will be revealed.
Stop fake posting!
All these ladies do is fake.
Wakepost!
It's all they do!
Oh my god.
You know what?
Plan.
Okay, good.
I don't know what was the plan there.
It's the only power they have.
I'm not sure if there's any...
I have so many, like, souls.
items, but it's like...
It's like...
I have nothing to upgrade.
You know?
My all-powerful boo.
I just have nothing to upgrade right now.
No!
Oh my god.
Alright.
Can't wait for my pair!
You even trying!
It's pair time!
Alright, give me my pair.
Also, why are you here?
This area is not gentrified yet.
I'd all but given up hope.
Please, take this as thanks.
Alright, nice.
Did I get a pair?
Oh, I got a socket.
Ooh, 60 or socket?
You know what, that's even better.
Actually, that...
Finally, someone gave me something good.
Oh my god.
All right, get over here.
Hey there, I'm dead.
Just lined up perfectly for me.
I have?
I guess from here, right?
Oh, I have.
Oh, it's this area!
I've cleared it out already.
This is where I prayed and received my blessing.
There's not a soul that could kill you.
me we'll see about that all right let's try it out see you
see that I'm protected by the gods I don't think like guys
is the right yeah popping up around you I just said oh my
god that's that's a little embarrassing oops Oh shit.
Incoming.
Oh my god, there's so many!
Let's keep sucking.
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Well done.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, I can bow and suck.
Alright, they're done.
Oh no, the ticks.
The face-huggers.
Oh, I mean that's easy.
What just happened?
I guess that was easy.
What?
I'm just gonna let that...
That's it?
That was anticlimactic?
Nothing mystical.
some manner of Genma was feeding on his heart oh yeah so
much for being invincible immortal by the way that's what
rendered him so untouchable and the Genma that only
protecting their comrade inside him I see the god enshrined
there is Dakiniten.
Dakiniten is said to protect the sick to their dying day.
Then feast on their heart in return.
Ah, that's like they can't hit him.
Because he came back to the site.
And this man's death They're a most- So because he like came
back to like where he got his powers, they're like it's
feeding time.
They were marinating him.
It's like wag you.
He has human wag you.
The grass fed him and everything.
Oh, it took me back here, too.
I mean, that's convenient.
Oh, okay, can I...
Okay, we have...
We should be able to enhance our...
Um...
What's here?
Why is there...
Oh, it's because it's new.
We can enhance our pouch now.
Because I didn't spend it on the...
Upgrade.
so i'm handsome i don't actually yeah i feel like i need
more hp there you go got it i think i can improve six now
all right affiliate thank you for the five gift of ships
thank you thank you
they say that she has a sworn enemy of the only no sooner
she appeared then she began wreaking havoc to hell as cool
as she is cunning and apparently clever enough to create new
gamma herself amongst the gamma there are none more devious
or dangerous just uh yoshitsune and dokyo master and servant
it's hard to conceive a worse pair each driven by an
insatiable thirst for blood and chaos they must be stopped
duck thank you this super chat thank you thank you is this
what you do to us when you feed us with merch are we wag you
dragons thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
your rough time, huh?
I have been enjoying this game a lot, though.
It's been really fun.
I really like the gameplay.
And the story's been, like, super interesting.
Huh?
I sense a murderous intent.
Not far from here.
Something terrible is happening.
A Gengar is on a rampage at Gojo-Hashi Bridge.
Oh, shit.
I knew the Onigate seemed weaker than usual.
Hmm.
The murderous presence you mentioned.
I recognize it.
It reminds me of a monk in Yoshitsune's entourage.
Oh, that'd be Benkei then.
They must have revived him as Gemma.
If that is the case, it would be Dokyo stewing.
Musashi, Benkei was monstrously strong, even as a human.
Let your guard down, and he'll turn you into a meatball.
Eniki.
Is that so?
He's like, ooh, yummy.
Gorgior, Hashibridge.
Any idea where it is?
Oh my god, okay, how bad is this boss?
According to Okuni, the malice around it is extremely thick.
Even if he went there, we would be unable to approach.
As such, let us deal with the source of the malice first.
I will guide you.
She's gonna guide me.
Alright.
How hard is this boss fight?
No.
Alright.
Let's see how hard.
Um.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, she's gonna clear it.
Clear it for me.
Alright.
Should be up here, right?
Yeah.
Destination.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wall ride time.
It's wall ride time.
It is no cause for concern.
I should order food before the restaurants close.
I'm ordering food right now.
Just in case.
Let's see.
I'm feeling like...
What do I feel like today?
I had...
I had spaghetti today.
I had Jolly B spaghetti.
I don't really want Jolly Bees.
Because I don't even want pasta.
Because I already had...
Let's see.
But yeah, I had Jolly Bees today.
So I should get something different.
What is open?
What is open that I can order?
I'm gonna grab.
Actually, throw it.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this.
I want ravioli.
I'm craving ravioli right now.
I don't know why.
I just really want ravioli.
Alright.
Ordered food.
Wait, actually.
What do I have right now?
Let's see.
Why?
Do I want any...
Do I want any appetizers?
Do I want any appies?
You know what?
I do.
I want appies.
All right.
Let me order food.
All right, got it.
All right, time.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's a lot of trees.
But it's pretty dark now.
Pretty dark and ominous.
Any loot?
Loot?
Me hungry for loot.
Can we go down?
Is that the culprit?
Without a doubt, the malice around it hangs thick.
We'll just have to grit and bear it.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Actually, guys, I'm...
Guys.
I might be a little too tired for Poison Swamp Part 2.
I...
Ah!
Okay.
I saw Poison Swamp, I'm like, no, I'm good.
I'm going to let future Dokey deal with poison swap.
Wait, that's new.
What's this?
Okay.
What do I get out of that?
Onystone, respond.
Run arrow.
Wait, what?
With Isan.
Oh, fucking, who gives a fuck about Isan?
I don't need no Isan.
Alright, we're going to call it Potokie.
It's a poisonous.
the poison swamp it's so fun all right we're gonna call it
here today i think we made i think we made a lot of progress
though in general i mean we completed like one entire
chapter technically like one entire area um so i think we
made a lot of progress i've been having a lot of fun um this
game has been very enjoyable um it's now not as hard anymore
when i figured um now that i know how to play the game.
Like, I know, it took me like, took me more than one part to
do it, like, not in part two, when I finally figured out how
to actually play the game.
Like, my Pali style for it, it's not as, then it's not as
hard.
It took me a while to figure it out, but it's not, it's not
as hard now.
Yeah, like when, I think it was just because I was so
overwhelmed with all the moves you can do, like, all the
controls in the game.
Um, That I didn't realize it was, you just gotta find your
playstyle.
And when I, yeah, I had to, when I finally found, figure out
my playstyle, everything just clicked in my head.
And it's like, yeah, during part one, there was just so much
to learn, so many different moves, so many different
controls, so many ways to like block or dodge or like figure
out what to block, what to parry, what to deflect.
But I realized, wait, I can just hold, I can just hold this
and just deflect.
time to deflect every time and it works like it literally
works i don't have to because like you know i made it so
much harder for myself trying to time this i could just
literally just do hold it hold it and it's everything got
got so much easier um but now now it's not the hardest whole
scheme i've ever played yeah um it's now i won't say this is
the hardest game i've ever played now after i figured it out
um i discovered the meta yeah um uh but yeah it's really fun
i'm enjoying the gameplay a lot i've been enjoying the story
a lot uh and i hope you guys have been having fun watching
tomorrow we'll be playing war dogs uh most likely uh ben
sherford and golly invited uh me to uh to play with them but
everyone we won't be like in bc or anything it's in squad
voice so it's gonna be fun we're gonna see i played war dogs
in the beta um but i was getting absolutely shit on so i
didn't have fun i didn't have fun because i was on i got
auto balance on the team against my friends so it was pretty
rough uh but but then they reassured me that it will be
different this time yeah they they reassured me that it will
be different if i'm on their if i'm on their team if i'm not
on their team i'm gonna queue up one without them because i
really do not want i do not want to get farmed non-stop by
my friends um um hey guys as always everybody stay get them
around and get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye